THE FIRST EDUCATION HEARING OF
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN THIS
MORNING THE SENATE ME ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEES ARE HOLDING
OUR ANNUAL.
JOINT HEARING ON BEHALF OF CAL
FOR THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF STUDENT COUNCILS WELCOME
STUDENTS.
STUDENTS WHO PARTICIPATE IN THE
ON THE STUDENT ADVISORY BOARD ON
LEGISLATION AND EDUCATION OF
WORK VERY HARD TO IDENTIFY
PROBLEMS RESEARCH ISSUES AND
DEVELOP LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS.
REPRESENTATIVES OF THIS ADVISORY
BOARD WILL PRESENT LEGISLATIVE
PERSONAL PROPOSALS TO US THIS
MORNING.
I HAVE RELLY ENJOYED HEARING
FROM ALL THE STUDENTS I AM THE
NEW CHAIR BUT I HAVE BEEN ON THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE FOR THE LAST
FOUR YEARS.
AND I ALWAYS PREFER APPRECIATE
YOUR PERSPECTIVE AND WHAT YOU
BRING TO US TODAY.
SO I WILL TURN IT OVER NOW TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL G.
LIKE TO MAKE A FEW OPENING
REMARKS -- I
I DO MANAGER AND THANK YOU AND
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE --
WE'RE HAPPY TO HEAR WHEN WILLING
TO HEAR YOUR VOICE IS A CASE FOR
SONY SO YOU ALL LOOK SO
PROFESSIONAL TODAY THE DO YOU
DON'T LOOK LIKE KIDS --
YOU KNOW SO SO THEY AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR YOUR COMMITMENT TO
IMPROVING CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS
WHICH YOU GUYS GO TO EVERY DAY.
OF MY BACKGROUND IS THAT I'M A
CLASSROOM TEACHER.
SO I TAUGHT MIDDLE SCHOOL FOR
FOURTEEN YEARS HIGH SCHOOL FOR
EIGHT AND I DID IN MY MIDDLE
SCHOOL TEACHING YEARS I ACTUALLY
RAN THE STUDENT COUNCIL FOR
SEVEN SEVERAL YEARS.
SO -- I
APPRECIATE THIS EXPERIENCE AND
THAT WERE HERE GEE WE'RE HERE TO
LISTEN TO YOU.
SO WITH THAT I'M GONNA TURN IT
BACK TO THE CHAIR.
THANK YOU.
BY SURE WOKE YOU OKAY YOU'RE
GOOD --
SENATOR CHANGE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
MAKE ANY OPENING REMARKS I KNOW
YOU'RE JUST GETTING SETTLED.
OKAY VERY GOOD WELL WE'RE
THRILLED TO HAVE YOU HERE SO
LET'S GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED.
WITH OUR FIRST GROUP.
AB OF RUMOR TALK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING AND AND WELCOME
THAT IT'S GREAT TO THAT YOU ARE
HERE -- YOU
HAVE THE AUSPICIOUS HONOR OF
JOINING ME FOR MY FIRST OF THESE
HEARINGS AND I COULDN'T BE MORE
THRILLED.
THAT IT IS WITH YOUR GROUP AS A
FORMER STUDENT BODY PRESIDENT OF
HEART HIGH SCHOOL I AM VERY
EXCITED THAT YOU'RE HERE AND
VERY HAPPY TO HEAR WHAT YOU HAVE
TO SAY.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE.
PLEASE PROCEED.
AT GOOD MORNING HONORABLE CHAIRS
SENATOR LEYVA AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL.
AS THE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES ON EDUCATION
AND GUESS.
MY NAME IS RACHEL LOU I'M A
SENIOR AT SOUTH PASADENA HIGH
SCHOOL IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND
I SERVICE THE STATE PRESIDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS OR WHAT WE
REFER.
TO CAST.
IS YOURS YOU KNOW VICE REPORT ON
LEGISLATION AND EDUCATION OR
SABLE HAS BROUGHT TOGETHER
STUDENTS FROM ALL OVER
CALIFORNIA TO PRESENT AND
REPRESENT THE STUDENT VOICE.
IS JUNE PRESENTATIONS WOULD NOT
HAVE BEEN PAUL.
THREE I WOULD LIKE TO COMMEND
ASSEMBLY CHIEF CONSULTANT TANYA
LIEBERMAN.
AND SENATE CHIEF CONSULTANT LYNN
LORBER FOR NOT ONLY MAKING THIS
JOINT HEARING POSSIBLE BUT ALSO
PROVIDING OUR STUDENTS WITH
VALUABLE ADDITIONAL INSIGHT LAST
NIGHT IN OUR DRYER AND PANEL.
OUR CONSISTENT PLATFORM OF
PRESENTATIONS TO THIS HONORABLE
COMMITTEE ARE NOT ONLY AN
UNPARALLELED OPPORTUNITY FOR
DELEGATES BUT AN UTMOST
RECOGNITION ON BEHALF OF THESE
COMMITTEES.
ON EDUCATION ON THE INCLUSION OF
THE STUDENT VOICE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE THANK YOU ALL FROM THE SIX
POINT THREE MILLION STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA AND WITHOUT FURTHER
ADO I EIGHT WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE.
THE CASK EDUCATION POLICY
DIRECTOR AND THE DIRECTOR OF
THIS CONFERENCE KENNETH KEPT.
THANK YOU MS LOW WELCOME KENNETH
CAM.
GOOD MORNING AND THANK YOU TO
TEARS LEYVA AND O'DONNELL AND
ESTEEMED MEMBERS OF BOTH THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES
ON EDUCATION.
MY NAME IS KENNETH CAM AND I'M A
SENIOR AT BRAILLE IN THE HIGH
SCHOOL IN THE BREA OLINDA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
THE EDUCATIONAL POLICY DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS AND THE
DIRECTOR OF THE STUDENT ADVISORY
BOARD ON LEGISLATION AND
EDUCATION CONFERENCE.
TWENTY NINETEEN THESE THAT THESE
THIRTY TWO DELEGATES BEHIND ME
ARE STRONG WILLED BILLION AND
PERCEPTIVE.
THEIR PASSION FOR EDUCATION AND
A DESIRE TO ACTIVELY WORK FOR
CHANGE INSPIRES NOT ONLY ME BUT
THE STAFF BEHIND ME.
WITH NO BIAS OR GUIDING FROM ANY
OF STAFF MEMBERS THIS YEAR'S
DELEGATES DEBATED VOTED AND
DECIDED ON FOR TOPICS THAT WILL
BE PRESENTING TODAY.
STUDENT INVOLVEMENT SCHOOL
FINANCES GENDER NON CONFORMING
INCLUSIVITY CURRICULUM REFORM
AND SEXUAL ASSAULT SUPPORT AND
SEXUAL HARASSMENT EDUCATION.
IN ADDITION THE LEGISLATIVE
POLICY COMMITTEE OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS HAVE DEVELOPED
THE PROPOSAL ON STATE FUNDING.
ON DAY ONE MONDAY THESE
DELEGATES FLUNG THEMSELVES INTO
A LONG BRAINSTORMING PROCESS
THAT OVER THE COURSE OF TWO DAYS
HAVE BEEN COMPRESSED INTO FORCES
THING PROPOSALS.
WE WORK LONG HOURS INTO THE
NIGHT LAYING OUT A FOUNDATION
FOR THE PROPOSAL VIA ROUTE
PROBLEMS ASSUMPTIONS CAUSES AND
EVIDENCE.
THE DELEGATES BUT UNDERSTAND
ATTIC KNOWLEDGE THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN STATE AND LOCAL POLICY
IDEAS HAVE KEPT THIS TO MY WHEN
EVALUATING ALL POSSIBLE
SOLUTIONS FOR THE FOUR TOPICS.
I AM CONFIDENT THAT WHEN THE
STUDENT ADVISORY BOARD ON
LEGISLATION EDUCATION PRESENTS
THE PROPOSAL TO COMBAT THE
ISSUES WITHIN AND CONCERNING
SCHOOL FINANCES.
NON BYNER GENDER INCLUSIVITY
SUPPORT AND SEXUAL REST
EDUCATION AND STAY FUNDING THE
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE OF THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES
ON EDUCATION WILL BE HEARING THE
MOST PRESSING CONCERNS OF THE
PAST YOU KNOW REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MR CAM.
LIKE TO INVITE UP OUR FIRST
PANEL.
I THINK UNDERSCORE FINANCES
INSTILLS SIENNA BOGART AND
STEPHEN CAM ARE STEPPING CAM
WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING HONORABLE
CHAIRWOMAN LEYVA CHAIRMAN
O'DONNELL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFF MEMBERS MY
NAME IS IAN CELLS AND I'M A
SENIOR SME HIGH SCHOOL IN
HOLLISTER CALIFORNIA.
AND MY NAME IS STEVEN KIM AND
I'M A SENIOR THIRTY WAS HIGH
SCHOOL IN FORCE IN CALIFORNIA
AND MY NAME SANTA BURGER AND I'M
A SENIOR AT NEWARK WHILE HIGH
SCHOOL IN YOUR CALIFORNIA.
IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY
NINETEEN CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
SCHOOLS RECEIVED A TOTAL OF
NINETY SEVEN POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS.
IN FUNDING FROM STATE LOCAL AND
FEDERAL SOURCES.
THAT'S LIKE EVERY PUBLIC SCHOOL
STUDENT IN CALIFORNIA WINNING A
TEN THOUSAND DOLLAR LUMP SUM.
YET STUDENTS HAVE VERY LIMITED
TO NO INPUT ON HOW THEIR LOCAL
DISTRICTS ALLOCATE THIS TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IN OUR IDEAL SCHOOL DISTRICT
[inaudible]
STUDENTS.
HAVE THEIR VOICES HEARD.
MY ADMINISTRATORS AND ALL
DECISIONS THAT WOULD IMPACT
THEIR EDUCATION.
OVER THE COURSE OF THE PAST FEW
DAYS MY FELLOW STUDENTS AND I
HAVE FOUND THAT CURRENTLY.
ONLY A SINGULAR PERSPECTIVE
EXISTS ON THE DISCUSSION
SURROUNDING DISTRICTS FINANCIAL
DECISIONS.
THIS LIKE A STUDENT INVOLVEMENT.
AND INPUT AND BUDGET PUTS A
STRAIN ON THE RELATIONSHIP
BETWEEN ADMINISTRATION AND
STUDENTS.
PUSHING THEM ONTO THE TWO
DIFFERENT SIDES OF THE SAME BY.
A LACK OF STUDENT INPUT AND
BUDGET COMMITTEES IS A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY FOR STUDENTS TO
UNDERSTAND THE COMPLEXITIES OF
SCHOOL FINANCING FOR DISTRICTS
TO BE BETTER CONNECTED WITH THE
NEEDS OF THEIR MAIN CONSTITUENTS.
THUS WE RECOMMEND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY AND
SURE THE INCLUSION OF STUDENT
REPRESENTATION AND DISTRICT
BUDGETING ADVISING COMMITTEES
DEMANDING THE CREATION OF BUDGET
ADVISORY COMMITTEES OUR BACKS.
THIS YEAR B THE BOARD A
LEGISLATION IN EDUCATION
PROPOSES THAT THE STATE
LEGISLATOR OVERSEE THE CREATION
OF STUDENT COMMITTEES.
IN ORDER TO ADVISE THEIR STUDENT
BOARD MEMBER AS WELL AS FOR BY
THE STUDENT PERSPECTIVE TO THE
SUPERINTENDENT ON THE DISTRICT'S
BUDGET THROUGH PRESENTATIONS AT
SCHOOL BOARD MEETINGS.
HE'S JUST HEARD BACK WOULD BE
RUN BY THE ALREADY ESTABLISHED
STUDENT BOARD MEMBER POSITION
AND PUBLIC SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
THIS CONNECTION WOULD ALLOW FOR
THE BACK TO EXIST AS ONE A BOARD
OF STUDENTS TO PROVIDE THEIR
PERSPECTIVE ON THE DISTRICT
BUDGET ISSUES AND TO A STUDENT
RESOURCE FOR STUDENT BOARD
MEMBERS TO STAY CONNECTED WITH
THEIR LARGE CONSTITUENT AREA.
ESSENTIALLY ARE BACK PROPOSAL
WOULD PROVIDE ESSENTIAL STUDENT
INPUT ON BUDGETARY ISSUES AND
CONSTITUENT CONNECTION. FOR THE
DISTRICTS YOU IMPORTANT FOR THIS
AFFECTED THE WOULD REMEDY THE
ISSUE OF THE LACK OF STUDENT
INPUT WITHIN SCHOOL DISTRICTS
FINANCING ACROSS ALL STATE
BALTIC.
AS MY COLLEAGUE HAS STATED
CREATING DISTRICT BUDGETING
ADVISORY COMMITTEES WOULD CREATE
A PLATFORM FOR STUDENTS THE MAIN
STAKEHOLDER IN PUBLIC EDUCATION.
TO COMMENT ON FUNDING ALLOCATION
AND TO ADDRESS PRIORITIES THEY
SEE IN CERTAIN AREAS.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT PRESENTLY
CERTAIN AVENUES TO EXIST FOR
STUDENT INPUT AND ONE PART OF
THE ALLOCATION.
PROCESS THERE IS A SHORT
PROVISION IN SECTION ONE OF THE
LOCAL CONTROL ACCOUNTABILITY
PLAN.
THAT REQUIRES STUDENT INPUT HOW
THE LANGUAGE AND INVOLVED IN
SECTION ONE OF THE CAP.
IS FAIRLY AMBIGUOUS AND BECAUSE
OF THIS NOT CONSISTENTLY
IMPLEMENTED THROUGHOUT ALL OF
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
ACCORDING TO THE CDC ONLY SEVEN
OUT OF THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
HAVE SOME FORM OF STUDENT
COMMITTEE TO ALLOW INPUT IN
THEIR SCHOOLS BUDGETS.
HOWEVER IN THE FEW SO I CASES
WERE BUDGET DECISIONS INVOLVE
STUDENTS SUCH AS IN THE CAP.
THERE APPEARS TO BE GREAT
SUCCESS.
IS BECAUSE OF THIS DEMONSTRATE
SUCCESS THAT WE WANT THE BUDGET
ADVISORY COMMITTEES TO BE A
FURTHER STEP INCORPORATING SOON
INVOLVEMENT IN BUDGET PROCESSES
AT THE HIGHER DISTRICT LEVEL.
AN EXAMPLE OF INNOVATION CAN BE
SEEN IN THE KERN HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN BAKERSFIELD
CALIFORNIA.
WHERE THERE EXISTS A NON
MANDATED EL CAP ADVISORY
COMMITTEE?
IT IS IMPORTANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THIS COMMITTEE IS JUST ONE
EXAMPLE ONE THAT IS NOT
WIDESPREAD AND ONE THAT IS
UNIQUE IN ITS EXISTENCE.
AN EXAMPLE OF ITS SUCCESS
STUDENTS WERE ABLE TO ADVOCATE
FOR AND BE INFORMED ON A IN BE
INFORMED ON A LOW INCOME SUMMER
FOOD PROGRAM.
CONDUCTED BY THE SCHOOL OF CUT
FUNDING.
THE ABILITY FOR STUDENTS
UNDERSTAND WE'RE SCHOOL FUNDS
WERE ALLOCATED COUPLED WITH A
PLATFORM FOR STUDENT FEEDBACK
ALLOWED FOR THE GREAT SUCCESS OF
THIS LOW INCOME SUMMER FOOD
PROGRAM.
IN THE CURRENT HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT WE OBSERVED THAT
STUDENTS WERE ABLE TO ENGAGE
WITH ADMINISTRATORS IN A UNIQUE
WAY.
AND TRULY COMPREHEND THE
DISTRIBUTION OF EL CAP FUNDS
THROUGH THEIR PARTICIPATION IN
THE ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
ONCE AGAIN IT IS IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT IN THIS SITUATION
STUDENTS ARE NOT INVOLVED IN THE
ENTIRETY OF THE DISTRICT BUDGET.
BUT ONLY THE LIMITED FUNDS UNDER
THE EL CAP LEAVE THAT THE
SUCCESSES THAT SHE FROM STUDENT
INPUT IN THE EL CAP COULD BE
AMPLIFIED IF STUDENTS WERE ABLE
TO OVERSEE DISTRICT THE ENTIRETY
OF THE DISTRICT BUDGET.
ED THROUGH A PROPOSAL THIS IS
ENTIRELY PLAUSIBLE ALREADY IN
GARDEN GROVE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO REPRESENTATIVES FROM
ALL THE DISTRICT'S SCHOOLS
CONVENE IN A MONTHLY MEETING.
WITH THE DISTRICT STUDENT BOARD
MEMBER AND SUPERINTENDENT.
HERE THE SUPERINTENDENT
ADDRESSES THE STUDENTS
INDIVIDUAL AND COMMUNITY ISSUES
ARE FOR DIRECT TO A
COMMUNICATION.
ALLOWING FOR FACILITATION OF
PROBLEM SOLVING AND
UNDERSTANDING BETWEEN THE TWO
PARTIES.
THIS OPEN A PRODUCTIVE
DISCUSSION RESOLVED OUR CONCERN
OF A DISTANCE ADMINISTRATION BY
AUGUST STUDENTS TO HAVE THEIR
CONCERNS HEARD AND PERIMETER
SHOOTERS TO BOTH HERE THESE
CONCERNS.
ADDRESS THEM.
AS A RESULT SUITS ARE MORE
INVESTED INTO THE DISTRICT AND
ITS FINANCIAL WELL BEING.
IT'S A WIN WIN FOR STUDENTS
EDITORS AT THEIR DISTRICTS.
THE BIG TO STUDENT VOICE IN
BUDGET DECISIONS GARDEN GROVE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND FOR
STUDENTS ABOUT THE PROPOSED
BUDGET IN THESE MEETINGS.
THESE MEETINGS UTILIZE THE SAME
SYSTEM OF PRODUCING CONVERSATION
BETWEEN THIS YEAR
REPRESENTATIVES THE CITY BOARD
MEMBER.
AND THE SUPERINTENDENTS ALONG
FOR A MULTIPLICITY OF
PERSPECTIVES AND PERMANENT
FEEDBACK OF THE BUDGETS MOST
IMPORTANT STAKEHOLDERS.
THE STUDENTS THEMSELVES.
I MUST REMEMBER MANY THE
SUPERINTENDENTS WERE ONCE HE
SEES.
INSTRUCTORS OF THE PEOPLE THE
CURRENTLY SIR.
BUT WITH DAILY POLITICS CASA
NEGOTIATION.
AND EVERYDAY ADULT LIFE.
IT'S EASY TO SEE WHY STUDENTS
CAN BE OVERLOOKED IN THE LIVES
OF THESE BUSY INDIVIDUALS.
THIS COMMITTEE PROVIDE THE
REINTRODUCTION OF STUDENTS AND
THEIR VERY REAL VERY LEGITIMATE
PERSPECTIVES INTO THE MIND OF
THE SCHOOL BOARD.
THOUGH NOT VOTING MEMBERS
STUDENTS INSIDE PROVED TO BE
INVALUABLE CONSIDERATIONS FOR
BOARD MEMBERS AND ADMINISTRATORS.
WITH IMPLEMENTATION OF OUR
PROPOSAL BOARD MEMBERS DECISIONS
WILL BE OBJECTIVELY AND
CONSISTENTLY INFORMED.
BY THIS COMMITTEE AND THE
RELEVANT INSIGHTS.
I BY CAN SUMMARIZE THIS PROPOSAL
INTO ONE SENTENCE.
BUT IT BE THIS.
STUDENTS IN THE ADVOCACY IN
BUDGET PLANS THROUGH STUDENT.
ADVISORY COMMITTEES WE ARE THE
STUDENTS BELIEVE ARE PLACES IN
THESE BUDGETING COMMITTEES AS WE
OFTENTIMES FUEL LOST AMONG THE
CONFUSING ALLOCATION OF
RESOURCES.
AND LACK OF SUPPORT FOR WHAT WE
NEED MOST.
THERE'S REALLY NOTHING STOPPING
THE CREATION OF THESE COMMITTEES.
FOR YOUR LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY
AT DISTRICTS WILLINGNESS TO
COOPERATE.
BY SUPPORTING THE CREATION OF
THESE COMMITTEES ACROSS OUR
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THE FUTURE DEMOCRACY IN OUR
EDUCATION.
WERE INFORMED ADULTS AND CONCERN
STUDENTS COME TOGETHER TO USE
THEIR MONETARY AN EDUCATIONAL
RESOURCES IN THE MOST EFFECTIVE
MANNER.
WE LIKE TO THANK YOU EACH FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION BAR
POSITION.
I WOULD NOW LIKE TO OPEN UP THE
FLOOR IT'S YOUR CONSTANT
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS VERY
COMPREHENSIVE MEMBERS ARE THERE
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH.
WELL I CONGRATULATE YOU ON WHAT
IS A PHENOMENAL PROPOSAL IT'S
GREAT FOR ME AS A LEGISLATOR TO
KNOW THAT ALL OF THE INTENT OF
OUR EL CAP PROCESS WAS TO ENGAGE
ALL STAKEHOLDERS --
IN THE BUDGETING FOR A DISTRICT
THAT THAT WE ARE FALLING SHORT
THERE SO I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR DILIGENCE IN YOUR HARD WORK
ON THIS.
DID YOU GIVE ANY CONSIDERATION
TO STUDENT REPRESENTATION ON
BOND OVERSIGHT COMMITTEES AS
WELL OR DID YOU LIMIT.
AND SIMPLY TO THAT THE OVERALL
DISTRICT INSIDE BUDGETS --
YOU'RE MORE LOOKING AT THE
DISTRICTS THEMSELVES BECAUSE
MOST OF THE CONTROL IS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL NOT REALLY LOOKING
TOO MUCH AT THESE LIKE BOARD
GRANTS CAM.
OKAY WELL PHENOMENAL WORK I
APPRECIATE IT THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
I'M CURIOUS --
IS THERE ANYTHING SPECIFIC THAT
YOU HAVE SEEN IN THE EL CAP
BUDGET THAT YOU WOULD LIKE TO
CHANGE OR YOU JUST LIKE TO HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE THERE AND
SEE HOW THE MONEY IS BEING
ALLOCATED.
MMHM OVER --
EXISTING THROUGH THE EL CAP
EIGHT IS A LITTLE AMBIGUOUS AND
INVOLVES ON REQUIRE --
INVOLVEMENT FROM THE COMMUNITY
AND ONE OF THOSE IF THAT TERMS I
AGREE I APOLOGIZE WELL INTO THE
POLICE FOR INVOLVEMENT IS I
STUDENT INVOLVEMENT IN THAT IT
LEAVES IT AT THAT.
WHICH ISN'T VERY COMPREHENSIVE
AND I COULD BE AS SIMPLE AS A
SCHOOL HAVING STUDENTS SIGN OFF
ON A PIECE OF PAPER SAYING THAT
THEY UDERSTAND EL CAP AND THAT
YOU INVOLVED THE STUDENT.
SO WE WERE HOPING THAT THROUGH
THIS EVEN THOUGH NOT ONLY
SPECIFIC TO THE OIL CAP. TO THE
ENTIRETY OF THE DISTRICT BUDGET
THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO INVOLVE
STUDENTS IN THAT MANNER.
GOOD VERY GOOD WELL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH EXCELLENT PRESENTATION
AND WILL CALL FOR NEXT PANEL.
THANK YOU.
SO OUR NEXT PANEL IS NON BINARY
GENDER INCLUSIVITY.
KILEY CHAUDRY KHLOE MADDEN AND
RAY PARKER COME ON UP.
WELCOME WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE YOU
HERE.
WHOEVER YOU WOULD LIKE TO GO
FIRST PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING AUDIBLE CHAIRWOMAN
LEYVA CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL AND TO
SEE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES ON EDUCATION.
NAME IS CALL HIM OUT IN AND I'M
A JUNIOR CREEL HIGH SCHOOL AND
THE GUITAR OR IN A PARK UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
MY NAME IS KILEY CHAUDRY AND I'M
A SENIOR AT MIDDLE COLLEGE HIGH
SCHOOL AND THE LARA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
MY NAME IS RAY PARKER AND I'M A
SOPHOMORE CREATE A HIGH SCHOOL
IN THE COULD TADI RUNNER PARK
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
I SIT HERE TODAY AS A NON BINARY
STUDENTS.
SOMEONE WHOSE GENDER IDENTITY
DOES NOT MATCH MALE OR FEMALE.
I REPRESENT THE OTHER NON BINARY
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA WHEN I
ASK THAT ALL SCHOOLS ARE
REQUIRED TO HAVE A GENDER
NEUTRAL BATHROOM THAT IS EASILY
ACCESSIBLE TO ALL STUDENTS.
I SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THESE NON
BINARY STUDENTS TO FEEL
INVALIDATED BY OUR CURRENT LACK
OF GENDER NEUTRAL RESTROOM
FACILITIES.
SCHOOL SHOULD BE A COMPLETELY
INCLUSIVE ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL
PEOPLE REGARDLESS OF GENDER
IDENTITY.
A PLACE WHERE GENDER NEUTRAL
RESTROOMS ARE JUST AS EASILY
ACCESSIBLE AS MALE OR FEMALE
RESTROOMS.
IN MY IDEAL SCHOOL PREFERRED
PRONOUNS IN NAMES ARE NOT ONLY
RESPECTED BUT ACCOUNTED.
FOR AND GENDER NON CONFORMING
USE EEL REPRESENTED REPRESENTED
AND VALUED WITHIN THEIR
COMMUNITY.
AS A SOCIETY WE HAVE MADE
TREMENDOUS STRIDES AND ACCEPTING
NON BINARY GENDER IDENTITIES THE
STATE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY HAVE
FURTHER THIS PROGRESSION IN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
HOWEVER THERE ARE STILL DEVISED
THAT BECAUSE GENDER NON%
CONFORMING USE TO BE HELD BACK
AND FEEL EXCLUDED AND ISOLATED
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES.
SPECIFICALLY IN OUR SCHOOLS. ONE
OF THE BIGGEST ISSUE SURROUNDING
GENDER INCLUSIVITY IS THE
APPROPRIATE RESTROOM FACILITIES.
AFTER SERVING STUDENTS FROM
AROUND THE STATE AT THIS
CONFERENCE THE MAJORITY OF
STUDENTS EXPRESSED THAT THEIR
SCHOOL DID NOT HAVE A GENDER
NEUTRAL RESTROOMS.
MOST SCHOOLS DON'T HAVE A GENDER
NEUTRAL RESTROOM AT ALL.
BUT THOSE WHO DO ARE ONLY
ACCESSIBLE THROUGH WALKING KEY
AND OFTEN DESIGNATED TO TEACHERS
AND STAFF.
STUDENTS MUST GO TO ACCEPT
EXTENSIVE LINKS JUST TO SIMPLY
USE THE RESTROOM.
CREATING A BARRIER THAT FURTHER
ISOLATES A GROUP THAT IS ALREADY
SENSITIVE TO SOCIAL EXCLUSION.
WHEN GOING TO SCHOOL OR ANYWHERE
IN PUBLIC FOR THAT MATTER I TRY
AT ALL COSTS TO AVOID USING THE
RESTROOM?
I DO THIS TO SKIP CONFLICT
THINGS ID IN THE INVALIDATION
THAT COMES ALONG WITH USING THE
RESTROOM BUT DOES NOT LINE UP
WITH MY GENDER IDENTITY.
IMAGINE NOT BEING ABLE TO USE
THE RESTROOM FROM EIGHT IN THE
MORNING UNTIL FOUR IN THE
AFTERNOON.
I GO THROUGH THIS SCENARIO
ALMOST EVERY SINGLE DAY.
PERSONALLY I CAN'T FOCUS DRINK
ENOUGH WATER.
OR SIMPLY ENJOY MY DAY WILL NOT
BEING ABLE TO USE THE RESTROOM.
THIS IS THE REALITY FOR MEN MANY
OF MY GENDER NON CONFORMING
PEERS.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE SIXTY SIX
SIX IN PASSED IN.
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN STATES
THAT STUDENTS CAN USE A FACILITY
THAT LINES UP WITH THEIR GENDER
IDENTITY REGARDLESS OF THEIR SEX
TO SIGN UP.
FOR HOWEVER THIS BILL DOES NOT
ACCOUNT FOR NON BINARY
INDIVIDUALS.
THE STUDENTS HAVE NO BATHROOM
THAT LINES UP WITH THEIR GENDER
IDENTITY.
PERSONALLY I KNOW THAT HAVING A
GENDER NEUTRAL BUT BATHROOM CAN
CULTIVATE A SAFE ENVIRONMENT AND
REDUCE THE STRESS THAT COMES
ALONG BUYER WITH OUR CURRENT
GENDER BINARY BATHROOM SITUATION.
CONTINUING OFF WILL RAISE OR YOU
PRESENTED WE HAVE IDENTIFIED THE
NEED FOR ALL SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA. TO INCLUDE A GENDER
NEUTRAL RESTROOMS THAT IS
UNLOCKED AND ACCESSIBLE TO ALL
STUDENTS K. THROUGH.
TWELVE IN THE CONTEXT OF THIS
PROPOSAL.
READILY ACCESSIBLE MEANS THAT
THE STEPS NECESSARY TO UTILIZING
THESE FACILITIES SHALL BE NO
DIFFERENT THAN THAT OF OUR OTHER
SCHOOL WIDE RESTROOMS.
LOCAL EDUCATION AGENCIES WILL BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION.
OF GENDER NEUTRAL RESTROOMS IN
SCHOOLS.
BUT IN THE CASE THAT SCHOOLS
ALREADY HAVE GENDER NEUTRAL
RESTROOMS THESE MUST BE MAKES US
WILL TO STUDENTS.
THE IMPLEMENTATION THIS PROPOSAL
MAY REQUIRE FUNDING AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL. FOR FOR SCHOOLS DO NOT
ALREADY HAVE A GENDER NEUTRAL
RESTROOMS THEY'LL BE REQUIRED TO
BUILD ONE AT THE EARLIEST
CONVENIENCE OUR NEXT
CONSTRUCTION PERIOD.
THIS WILL ENCOURAGE SUBSTANTIAL
ADDITIONAL COST.
IN THE CASE OF SCHOOLS HAVE
ACCESS TO AN EXISTING ADDITIONAL
RESTROOM.
THEY MAY TRANSITION THIS
RESTROOM TO A GENDER NEUTRAL
SPACE.
WITH THE FULL COST OF A CRATE
REOCCURRING MAINTENANCE FOR THE
FACILITY.
WE UNDERSTAND COSTA HIGH WE
BELIEVE THAT THE RESULTS FOR
STUDENTS WILL BE WORTH IT.
YOUR RESEARCH WE DISCOVERED THAT
THERE IS NO BILL REQUIRING
PUBLIC SCHOOLS TO HAVE A GENDER
NEUTRAL RESTROOMS.
WELL ALTHOUGH ASSEMBLY BILL
SEVENTY THIRTY TWO PASSED IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN REQUIRES ALL
PUBLIC FACILITIES WITH A SINGLE
STALL RESTROOM TO BE LABELED AS
GENDER NEUTRAL SCHOOLS ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO HAVE A SINGLE STALL
RESTAURANT.
THOSE WHO DON'T IDENTIFY WITH
EITHER THE MALE OR FEMALE GENDER.
HAVE LITTLE TO ACCESS TO GENDER
NEUTRAL FACILITIES TODAY.
THIS EXTRA BERRIER ISOLATES THEM.
INCREASE UNHEALTHY STIGMA
SURROUNDING THEM.
THIS OFTEN STEMS FROM A LACK OF
UNDERSTANDING ON THE TOPIC
CREAMY BY A SENSE OF PREJUDICE
AND DISCRIMINATION.
EDUCATIONAL ENVIRONMENT AS SOON
IS INVOLVED IN TODAY IS CRUCIAL
TO THE FUTURE.
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO MAKE THAT
AS SUPPORTIVE AS PROGRESSIVE AS
POSSIBLE.
A PERFECT EXAMPLE.
IN OUR CURRENT SOCIAL CLIMATE.
PEOPLE ARE COMING MORE MORE
ACCEPTING OF THOSE WHO DON'T
CONFORM TO NUTRITIONAL STATUS
QUOTES.
A PERFECT EXAMPLE OF THIS BEING
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTEEN
PASSED IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WHICH
REQUIRES AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION PROVIDE SUPPORT TO
USE AND THEIR FAMILIES WHO HAVE
BEEN VICTIMS OF HARASSMENT AND
BULLYING.
ON THE BASIS OF GENDER IDENTITY.
BOOK GENDER SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
AND GENDER EXPRESSION.
THE STATE HAS FORTY EXPRESS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR STUDENTS AND
THEIR GENDER IDENTITY AND WE'RE
GRATEFUL FOR THAT [inaudible]
HOWEVER.
WE SHOULD EXTEND AND CONTINUE
THIS MOMENTUM. TO STUDENTS WHO
DON'T CONFORM TO THE TRADITIONAL
BINARY SCALE.
WELL IT ISSUE SEEM DAUNTING MANY
INSTITUTIONS HAVE ALREADY
SUCCESSFULLY IMPLEMENTED AND
SUPPORTED GENDER NEUTRAL
FACILITIES.
THE BISHOP SCHOOL IS ONE OF
THREE SCHOOLS IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY TO HAVE GENDER NEUTRAL
RESTROOMS.
WITH THE STUDENT POPULATION OF
EIGHT HUNDRED IN GRADES SIX
THROUGH TWELVE BISHOP SCHOOL
MAINTAINS FIVE GENDER NEUTRAL
RESTROOMS.
DINNER NEUTRAL RESTROOMS WOULD
REMOVE THE PERCEIVED PROBLEM OF
SPECIAL TREATMENT FOR THE FEW.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS NON BINARY
STUDENTS WERE ALLOWED TO USE THE
LOCKED RESTROOMS.
IN ADDITION GENDER NEUTRAL
RESTROOMS WOULDN'T INCREASE THE
AMOUNT OF CONFIDENCE OF NON
BINARY INDIVIDUALS AND DECREASE
THE AMOUNT OF HARASSMENT
BULLYING THAT THE STUDENTS
EXPERIENCE.
REFERRING BACK TO REYES PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE IS COMMON THE NON
BINARY INDIVIDUALS ARE OFTEN
VERY ANXIOUS REGARDING RUSSIAN
USE.
ADDING THESE RESTAURANTS TO
SCHOOLS WILL MAKE THE STUDENTS
FEEL INCLUDED SUPPORTED AND
RESPECTED BY THEIR MINISTRATION
DISTRICT AND STATE.
THE RESTROOMS WILL HELP
NORMALIZE THE CONCEPT OF GENDER
NON CONFORMITY AND WILL INCREASE
THE GENDER DIVERSITY WITHIN
SCHOOLS.
ADDITIONALLY ON ISSUE THE
DIALOGUE ON GENDER IDENTITY
INCLUSION LOWER THE STIGMA
BETWEEN BINARY AND NON BINARY
PEOPLE.
ESTABLISH SECURITY IN GENDER
EXPRESSION AND LOWER THE ANXIETY
OF PEOPLE GOING TO SCHOOL.
AS A RESULT STUDENTS WILL FEEL
VALUED AND HEARD WITHIN THEIR
STUDENT BODY.
WE ASK THAT YOU PROVIDE THE SAFE
PLACE TO THE CALIFORNIA USED TO
IDENTIFIES DOWNTURN ON
CONFIRMING.
AND FULFILL THE PROMISE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. TO PROVIDE
AN INCLUSIVE AND CONDUCIVE
LEARNING AND ENVIRONMENT TO ALL
STUDENTS.
WE CANNOT CLAIM THAT CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS ARE INCLUSIVE UNTIL
INCLUDE EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU STAY THERE IN CASE
ANYONE ASKING QUESTIONS.
MISTER CHAIR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
A THE U. EFFORT FIRST A COMMENT --
VERY WELL PRESENTED --
VERY THOROUGH SO SO EXCELLENT
JOB THERE IN YOUR PRESENTATION --
WITH REGARD YOUR PROPOSAL ARE
YOU SEEKING TO HAVE GENDER
NEUTRAL BATHROOM BATHROOMS AT
ALL LEVELS MANY ELEMENTARY
MIDDLE AND HIGH.
ARE YOU JUST THINKING HIGH OR OR
HAVE YOU NOT CONCLUDED ON A TEMP
COME TO A CONCLUSION THE REST BY
THAT WE WOULD APPRECIATE
GENERAL'S RESTROOMS AT ALL K.
THROUGH TWELVE GRADES.
AT ALL WHAT I'M SORRY K. THROUGH
TWELVE GRADES KINDERGARTEN
THROUGH TWELFTH GRADE A SO ANY
SCHOOL SITE YES ANY SCHOOLS.
IN WITH REGARD TO ACCESS THIS
THIS -- IF
IF TO IDENTIFIES NON BINARIES
THAT CORRECT YES OKAY THANK YOU.
THE OTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
WELL I WOULD JUST SAY RAY THANK
YOU FOR SHARING YOUR STORY AND I
THINK ALL OF YOU WHEN YOU COME
YOU MAKE US BETTER LEGISLATORS
BECAUSE SOMETIMES WE FORGET WHAT
IT'S LIKE. TO HAVE BEEN IN K.
THROUGH TWELVE AND SOMETIMES WE
DON'T ALWAYS SHARE YOUR
EXPERIENCE SO VERY WELL
PRESENTED AND YOU'VE GIVEN US A
LOT OF FOOD FOR THOUGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'D LIKE TO INVITE UP OUR NEXT
GROUP.
KEIRA KEENAN HON CAM AND ALL
OVER FRENCH.
WE TALK ABOUT CURRICULUM REFORM
THIS SOUNDS VERY INTERESTING AS
WELL.
GOOD AFTERNOON AUDIBLE
CHAIRWOMAN LEYVA CHAIRMAN
O'DONNELL AND I SEE MEMBERS OF
THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEES AND EDUCATION.
MY NAME IS JOHN CAN AND I'M A
JUNIOR ATTENDING SOUTH PASADENA
HIGH SCHOOL OF THE SOUTH
PASADENA UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
MY NAME IS CURE KEENAN AND I'M A
SENIOR CURRENTLY ATTENDING
MARYLAND HIGH SCHOOL AT SAN JUAN
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SACRAMENTO COUNTY.
MY NAME IS OLIVER FRENCH AND I'M
A SOPHOMORE ATTENDING HIGH
SCHOOL OF THE QATARI VOTER PARK
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
THERE IS A COMMONLY ACCEPTED
IDEA THAT LIFE AFTER HIGH SCHOOL
CAN BE A DAUNTING TASK.
AT THE AGE OF EIGHTEEN THE
OBLIGATIONS OF ADULTHOOD BEGIN
TO SAID IN.
KNOWING HOW TO BUDGET YOUR
PERSONAL FINANCES PREPARE FOR A
JOB INTERVIEW AND MAINTAIN A
GOOD CREDITSCORE ALL THINGS AND
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF ONE'S
LIFE.
AND EASE THE TRANSITION BETWEEN
ADOLESCENCE AND ADULTHOOD.
WE A STUDENTS RECOGNIZE A
CALIFORNIA'S CURRICULUM FAILS TO
PROVIDE EDUCATION ON SKILLS
ESSENTIAL TO A SUCCESSFUL LIFE
AFTER HIGH SCHOOL.
IN SHORT NOT RICH AMERICAN HIGH
SCHOOL OVERLOOKS THE FACT THAT
STUDENTS NEED INSTRUCTION ON
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT.
TAX FILING JOB PREPAREDNESS AND
MANY MORE GENERALIZED SKILLS.
THE LACK OF A STANDARDIZED
CURRICULUM IN A REQUIRED
GOVERNMENT AND ECONOMIC COURSES
LIKE COVERAGE ON TOPICS LIKE
COMPREHENSIVE FINANCIAL LITERACY.
THIS IMAGINABLE BRIDGE
DETRIMENTAL TO OUR SOCIETY.
WITH THE CURRENT CURRICULUM
STUDENTS ARE NOT TAUGHT HOW TO
PREPARE FOR SUCCESSFUL JOB
INTERVIEW MANAGE THEIR INCOME OR
NAVIGATE THE AMERICAN TAX SYSTEM.
THIS INFORMATION IS PARAMOUNT
FOR FUNCTIONING IN THE WORLD
OUTSIDE OF SCHOOL.
HOW CAN THIS GENERATION
PARTICIPATE IN THIS WORLD WHEN
THEY'RE NOT PREPARED WITH THESE
FUNDAMENTAL SKILLS?
AND THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
NATIONAL REPORT CARD CREATED BY
THE CENTER FOR FINANCIAL
LITERACY OF CHAMPLIN COLLEGE THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA RECEIVED IN
F. ONE GRADED ON CRITERIA
CRITERIA BASED ON SAY EFFORTS TO
IMPROVE FINANCIAL LITERACY.
WE BELIEVE THAT THE REASON FOR
THIS FAILING GRADE IS BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA'S K. THROUGH TWELVE
EDUCATION CURRENTLY DOES NOT
REQUIRE ANY COMPREHENSIVE
FINANCIAL CURRICULUM. TO BETTER
UNDERSTAND THE EXTENT OF THIS
ISSUE LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT SOUTH
PASADENA HIGH SCHOOL.
MANY EXTRACURRICULAR CLASSES
REQUIRE JOB SKILLS SUCH AS
RESUME WRITING.
BETTER SOON TO HAVE BEEN LEARNED
BUT ARE NEVER FORMALLY TAUGHT IN
ANY COURSE.
THIS FAILURE TO TEACH BASIC LIFE
SKILLS IS A SERIOUS ISSUE IN
EDUCATION.
AS A RESULT STUDENTS OFTEN FEEL
ILL PREPARED TO PUT TO APPLY TO
ON CAMPUS OPPORTUNITIES
NONETHELESS OFF CAMPUS JOBS.
HOWEVER SOME SCHOOLS HAVE TAKEN
IT UPON THEMSELVES TO MEET
STUDENT CONCERNS ABOUT THE
UNCERTAINTY THEY FACE IN LIFE
BEYOND HIGH SCHOOL. FOR EXAMPLE
AT ENTERPRISE HIGH SCHOOL IN
REDDING TEACHERS HAVE CHOSEN TO
TEACH LE SCHOOLS BECAUSE THEY
FEEL THAT IT IS A NECESSARY PART
OF EDUCATION.
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE A
TEACHER WHEN IS THE NEED FOR
STUDENTS TO LEARN HOW TO WRITE A
RESUME AND PREPARE FOR AN
INTERVIEW.
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANCE OF
THESE DANCE VOLUNTARILY TEACH
THESE THINGS AND THE TIME
FOLLOWING AN A. P. EXAM.
THIS NEED IS NOT JUST RECOGNIZE
BY ADULTS.
BUT STUDENTS ARE CONSTANTLY
LOOKING TOWARDS OUR FUTURE
RESPONSIBILITIES ANALYZE AS WELL.
ADDITIONAL IN A CREDO HIGH
SCHOOL IN ROHNERT PARK AN ADULT
IN CLASS WAS IMPLEMENTED A
POPULAR REQUESTS FROM STUDENTS.
STUDENTS WRENCHED EXTREMELY
ENTHUSIASTIC ABOUT THE ELECTIVE
CLASS.
EVEN THOUGH HIS EFFORTS WERE
VERY WELL RECEIVED BY STUDENTS
THERE'S BEEN LITTLE EXPANSION OF
THESE TEACHING METHODS AT THE
STATE LEVEL.
ULTIMATELY WE'RE DRIVING OUR
GENERATION TO ACHIEVE HIGH TEST
SCORES AND PROCEDURES COLLEGE
ACCEPTANCES AND I FELL TO STRESS
THE IMPORTANCE OF OBTAINING THE
NECESSARY KNOWLEDGE TO OVERCOME
THE HARDSHIPS OF ADULTHOOD.
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH
CALIFORNIA STRIVING TO
ACADEMICALLY PREPARE STUDENTS
pFOR COLLEGE BUT WE CANNOT FOR
AFFORD TO FORGET TO PREPARE THEM
FOR TOSSES WILL. TO SPEAK ON MY
EXPERIENCE I CURRENTLY ATTEND
MARYLAND HIGH SCHOOL WHICH A
COURT IN ANY SHOULD RANKS THIRTY
THIRD IN COLLEGE PREPAREDNESS OF
THE ONE THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
AND THIRTY FOUR PUBLIC HIGH
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT
EVEN ACADEMICALLY RIGOROUS
SCHOOLS LIKE MIRA LOMA ARE
INADEQUATE IN THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF A LIFE SKILLS PREVIOUSLY
ADDRESSED.
I MENTION THIS ONLY TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT COLLEGE IS
SIMPLY ONE OF THE MANY ASPECTS
OF THE ADULT WORLD STUDENTS FACE
OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL.
THUS A LIFE SKILLS CURRICULUM
WOULD MEET THE STUDENTS NEEDS OF
COLLEGE PREPARATION AS WELL AS
THE SKILLS NECESSARY FOR SUCCESS
BEYOND COLLEGE.
WE RECOGNIZE THE JOINT EFFORTS
MADE BY STUDENTS AND THEIR
SCHOOLS TO IMPROVE ACADEMIC
SKILLS AND RIGOR.
STUDENTS LIKE MYSELF ARE
PERFORMING AT AHIGH ACADEMIC
LEVEL IN PREPARATION FOR COLLEGE.
HOWEVER WE ARE LIMITED BY THE
LACK OF AN ENFORCED AND
STANDARDIZED CURRICULUM IN AREAS
OF JOB PREPAREDNESS AND
FINANCIAL LITERACY.
SO CONSIDER ASKING OURSELVES.
WHAT GOOD IS EDUCATION IF YOU DO
NOT KNOW HOW TO APPLY IT?
IN AN ATTEMPT TO ADDRESS
STATISTICAL CONCERNS IT IS
IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTAND THAT THE
NEXT GEN PERSONAL FINANCE
RESEARCH REPORT.
FINDS ONLY ONE IN.
SIX HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
NATIONWIDE ARE REQUIRED TO TAKE
A PERSONAL FINANCE COURSE TO
GRADUATE.
WHAT IS MORE IS THAT ONE IN
TWENTY HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS FROM
LOW INCOME BACKGROUNDS ARE
REQUIRED TO TAKE A PERSONAL
FINANCE COURSE FROM STATES
WITHOUT MANDATES?
SO BECOMES CLEAR THAT THE
STUDENTS WHO SUFFER THE MOST ARE
THE ONES THAT ARE LEAST EDUCATED
ON FINANCIAL LITERACY.
ON THE SUBJECT OF CURRENT
EDUCATION CODE EDUCATION CODE
SECTION FIVE ONE TWO EIGHT FIVE
POINT.
FIVE SUBSECTION A STATES THAT
WHEN THE HISTORY SOCIAL SCIENCE
CURRICULUM FRAMEWORK IS REVISED
AFTER JANUARY FIRST.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE
INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY COMMISSION
SHALL CONSIDER THE INCLUSION OF
CURRICULUM RELEVANT TO HOW TO
USE A SAVINGS AND CHECKING
ACCOUNTS.
HOW TO MAINTAIN A BUDGET?
EMPLOYMENT [inaudible]
LOANS INSURANCE FORMS OF
TAXATION INVESTING IDENTITY
THEFT PLANNING AND PAYING FOR
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION AND
CHARITABLE GIVING.
EDUCATION CODE SECTION THREE
THREE FIVE FOUR ZERO
INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY COMMISSION
SHALL ENSURE.
THAT THE CURRICULUM INCLUDES
INFORMATION REGARDING A VOTER
EDUCATION.
HOW TO REGISTER HOW TO REQUEST
AN ABSENTEE BALLOT?
HOW TO FIND A POLLING PLACE AND
EVEN HOW TO PAY FOR COLLEGE?
WE PROPOSE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
AMEND THESE EDUCATION CODES
WHICH CONCERN FINANCIAL LITERACY
AND CIVIC EDUCATION.
THE AMENDMENTS CONTAIN IMPORTANT
TOPICS THEIR ABSENT FROM THE
SECTIONS OF THE EDUCATION CODE.
INCLUDING HOW TO FILE TAXES HOW
TO COMPLETE JOB APPLICATIONS
INTERVIEWS HOW TO WRITE RESUMES
AND COVER LETTERS.
AND HOW TO PRE REGISTER TO VOTE.
AMENDMENTS SHOULD ALSO INCLUDE
STANDARDS PERTAINING TO CIVIC
ENGAGEMENT.
PROFESSIONAL ETIQUETTE
RETIREMENT PLANS AND MAINTAINING
A GOOD CREDIT SCORE.
WE URGE THE LEGISLATURE TO PASS
THIS BILL AND EXPRESS OUR
CONCERN TO THE AYE QC AND TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR WHEN REVIEWS
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT CURRICULUM
AND LOOKS ARE POSSIBLE
AMENDMENTS IN THE FRAMEWORK.
WITH THESE AMENDMENTS STUDENTS
WILL BE PREPARED FOR LIFE AFTER
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS WILL HAVE
AN EASIER TIME PURSUING SPECIFIC
YOUR PAST DUE TO A SURPLUS OF
KNOWLEDGE AND PREPARATION.
STUDENTS BECOME AWARE OF THEIR
OBLIGATIONS AS ADULTS AND WILL
SUCCEED IN FEELINGS OBLIGATIONS
AS SUCCESSFUL.
AND PRODUCTIVE MEMBERS OF
SOCIETY.
THIS PROPOSAL NOT ONLY ENSURES
THAT VALUABLE SKILLS ARE
AVAILABLE ALL SCHOOLS IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THE ALL STUDENTS
ARE ABLE TO BENEFIT FROM THE
TEACHING OF THESE VALUABLE
SKILLS.
CAREER AND TECHNICAL EDUCATION
CITY COURSES ARE AVAILABLE AND
MANY HIGH SCHOOLS.
BUT FAILED TO ENCOMPASS A
COMPREHENSIVE CURRICULUM THAT
INCLUDES ALL ASPECTS OF ADULT
LIFE.
AND EVEN THEN CITY EACH CLASSES
ARE OFTEN ELECTIVES SO SOME
STUDENTS OPT OUT OF AN
OPPORTUNITY IF THEY DON'T KNOW
THEY NEED.
OR STUDENTS WHO WANT THIS
SELECTIVE SIMPLY CAN'T TAKE IT
DUE TO A SCHEDULING COMPLICATION.
WHAT WE PROPOSES AMENDING THE AT
CO TO INCLUDE THESE ESSENTIAL
ASPECTS OF ADULTHOOD IN
ECONOMICS AND AMERICAN
GOVERNMENT CLASSES? TO THE EVERY
STUDENT FEELS CONFIDENT WHEN
THEY WALK INTO AN INTERVIEW.
PREPARED WHEN FILING TAXES AND
THEY KNOW THE LIFE OUTSIDE OF
SCHOOL.
STUDENTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA ARE
HUNGRY FOR THIS KNOWLEDGE THERE
ARE THOSE WHO DESPERATELY WANT
TO LEARN MORE ON THESE TOPICS.
AND THERE ARE THOSE WHO NEED
THIS MATERIAL AND MIGHT NOT
REALIZE THAT.
WE FEEL A RESPONSIBILITY TO ALL
THE STUDENTS TO ENSURE THAT
THERE IS PREPARED AND EXCITED
FOR THE WORLD BEYOND HIGH SCHOOL
AS THEY SHOULD BE.
WE HAVE CONFIDENCE THAT THIS
LEGISLATION WILL GUARANTEE THE
FUTURE FINANCIAL AND FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
STABILITY FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION.
THANK YOU ALL FOR LISTENING WE
NOW OPEN THE FLOOR FOR COMMENTS
AND QUESTIONS.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU [inaudible]
MISTER CHAIR.
I YES THANK YOU I THANK YOU --
A FIRST ROLL I AGREE WITH YOU
THAT --
PERSONAL FINANCE NEEDS TO BE
TAUGHT AT THE HIGH SCHOOL LEVEL.
I VERY MUCH SUPPORT THAT CONCEPT
IN FACT DID IT FOR MANY YEARS.
DID INSIDE THIS SENIOR ECONOMICS
CLASS OF MY STUDENTS WOULD TAKE
BECAUSE THE ECONOMICS CURRICULA
IS ACTUALLY NOT THAT WHITE.
HE CAN ACTUALLY COVER MOST OF IT
WITHIN A PRETTY REASONABLE
AMOUNT OF TIME THAT YOU HAVE
SOME TIME LEFT OVER THE SEMESTER.
AND YOU CAN YOU KNOW DEFENDER TO
TO PERSONAL FINANCE MORE
EXTENSIVELY THAN YOU WOULD
OTHERWISE AND WHEN I SEE
PERSONAL FINANCE PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT BALANCING A CHECKBOOK.
NO ONE REALLY BALANCE A
CHECKBOOK ANYMORE THEY GO ON
THEIR COMPUTER RIGHT NOW A LOOK
AT WHAT'S GOING ON BUT REALLY
WHAT'S IMPORTANT ME AS PER AND
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT PERSONAL
FINANCES INVESTING FOR
RETIREMENT.
MAYBE FOR A HOME.
AND THE FOUR ONE K. STOCK MARKET
THINGS LIKE THAT BECAUSE THE
PENSION WORLD IS IS CHANGED FOR
SURE.
SO PEOPLE NEED TO DO THAT ON
THEIR OWN AND THEY NEEDED KNOW
HOW TO DO THAT.
ON THEIR OWN --
AND WHAT IS ALONE MAIN LONG TERM
TO MY CREDIT WHAT IS I MEAN I
DON'T PAN OUT WHAT IS A CREDIT
CARD MEAN BECAUSE A LOT OF
PEOPLE GOING TO COLLEGE TO GET
THEIR CREDIT CARD RIGHT.
RYAN LOOKING MAYBE SOME WAS
GUILTY OR I DON'T KNOW BUT I
KNOW I WAS A TO PAY THAT OFF
THAT INTEREST RATE IS VERY HIGH --
AND YOU CAN LEARN BY KNOWING YOU
AN LEARN BY DOING SOMETIMES
BETTER TO LEARN BY KNOWING.
AND YOU CAN KNOW IF YOU LEARN IS
CERTAINLY IN YOUR HIGH SCHOOL
EXPERIENCE WHAT I WOULD SAY IS --
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IS I
ACTUALLY SUPPORT THIS BUT I
WOULD SAY TO LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WHO WANT IF THEY CAN
DO IT TODAY.
THEY'RE ALREADY ADDING ON
GRADUATION REQUIREMENTS AT THE
LOCAL LEEL AND THEY SHOULD BE
DOING.
IT IN THIS CASE AS WELL OCT IF
WE MANDATE IT FROM THE STATE
LET'S SAY THE STATE SAYS YOU
HAVE TO TAKE THIS CLASS YOU HAVE
TO STUDY THIS CURRICULUM.
WHAT THAT MEANS IS IT'S GONNA BE
SCORED AS A MANDATE WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO PAY EVERY SCHOOL
DISTRICT ACROSS THE STATE? TO TO
PROVIDE THAT CLASS RENTS PAVE
THE TEACHER TIME EXCEDRIN GETS
VERY EXPENSIVE IT'S MORE OF A
BURDEN ON THE GREATER STATE
BUDGET DOESN'T MEAN THAT WE
DON'T DO IT WE ARE YOU IT MANY
CASES.
BUT ON A MORE AND IT MORE
IMMEDIATE. FOR LOOKING AT A WHAT
FOR THE FOR THE FOR THE SHORT
TERM I THINK THE BEST WAY FOR
THIS TO BE HANDLED IS FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
AT THEIR NEXT BOARD MEETING
ADOPT A POLICY THAT OUR STUDENTS
ARE TO GRADUATE --
A GRADUATION REQUIREMENT THAT
WOULD SAY HEY YOU GOT IT YOU
KNOW HAVE SOME SOME SOME
EXPERIENCE AND PERSONAL FINANCE
AND I THINK AGAIN.
THE ECONOMICS.
CLASS IS IS IS THE NATURAL PLACE
NOT ONLY BECAUSE OF ITS NAME
BECAUSE OF THE HOW THE
CURRICULUM IS WRITTEN OUT SO ALL
JUST I'LL JUST LEAVE YOU WITH
THAT -- BUT
AGAIN GREAT IDEA PEOPLE NEED TO
KNOW PERSONAL FINANCE I WOULD
ARGUE THESE WE TAUGHT IN COLLEGE.
TOO QUITE FRANKLY AS PART OF A
GENERAL ED REQUIREMENTS BUT
THAT'S ANOTHER CONVERSATION BUT
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
VERY WELL THANK.
YOU THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH AND THEN
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION AND
THE FACT THAT YOU ARE THINKING
ABOUT THESE ISSUES ON BEHALF OF
YOUR PEERS IS IS SIGNIFICANT.
AND YOU KNOW NOT ON LIKE --
THE CHAIR MISTER O'DONNELL I DO
AGREE THAT FROM THE STATE'S
LEGISLATIVE PERSPECTIVE WE DO
NEED TO BE VERY CAREFUL ABOUT
WHAT BECOMES AT AT WHAT'S KNOWN
AS AN UNFUNDED MANDATE --
BUT I DO THINK GOING FORWARD AS
WE TALK ABOUT --
FULLY FUNDING K. TWELVE
EDUCATION --
IN A WAY THAT IS MEANINGFUL AND
ALLOWS US TO BE SUPPORTIVE OF
ALL OF THESE KIND OF PROGRAMS.
THAT THIS IS PROBABLY A COURSE
WORTHY AS A STANDALONE AYE
NEWMAN AYE OBVIOUSLY THERE'S
ROOM FOR IT NOW IN THE ECONOMICS
CURRICULUM BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE FULL SPECTRUM.
OF THE ISSUES THAT YOU POINTED
OUT JOB RESUMES ENGAGING WITH
YOUR LOCAL GOVERNMENT HOW TO TO
FILE YOUR TAXES THERE ARE SO
MANY ASPECTS NOW OF BEING READY
TO ENGAGE IN ADULT LIFE
PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE WHO GO ON
TO IMMEDIATELY PURSUE OF
OCCASIONAL CAREER.
OR GO ON TO COLLEGE AND ARE
ASSUMING THAT DEBTAND WHAT THAT
MEANS IS CERTAINLY THINK THERE'S
ENOUGH CONTENT HERE BUT WHERE WE
ARE NOT.
OUT YET IS A PLACE WHERE WE CAN
PROBABLY ADD ON ANOTHER
SIGNIFICANT PIECE OF CURRICULUM
WITHOUT FUNDING TO BACK THAT UP
SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU IN YOUR
PEERS ON TO STAY.
WITH US ON THIS ISSUE AS WE
CONTINUE TO MOVE FORWARD
PROBABLY THE BEST AVENUE RIGHT
NOW IS TO PURSUE THIS WITH LOCAL
DISTRICTS AND THOSE THAT HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO EXPAND.
BUT IT IS CERTAINLY WORTHWHILE
AND SOMETHING THAT WE NEED.
THANK YOU SOME A MEMBER RUSSELL
[inaudible]
OKAY.
HI.
BUT YOU KNOW THERE'S A NEW
SLOGAN THAT'S BEEN POPULARIZED
AND IT SAYS THIS IS WHAT
DEMOCRACY LOOKS LIKE.
IF ANYBODY'S BEEN OUT ON THE
MARCH THAT'S WHAT'S USED --
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU.
FOR ALL OF THESE PRESENTATIONS
NOT JUST YOUR OWN --
BECAUSE I DO THINK THAT YOU ARE
MAKING PROPOSALS.
THAT GROW DEMOCRACY IN OUR WHOLE.
STATE IN OUR WHOLE SOCIETY SO
THAT'S THE FIRST THING I WANT TO
SAY.
AND I SPECIFICALLY --
OF BELIEVE THE PROPOSAL THAT YOU
MADE TODAY IS REALLY IMPORTANT
WE'VE LOST SO MANY.
LIFE SKILLS.
OUR TYPE OF CLASSES OVER THE
YEAR TO BE SO FOCUSED ON GOOD
THINGS LIKE MATH AND SCIENCE
THAN OTHERS AND I'M NOT SAYING
TO DO AWAY WITH THOSE AND I KNOW
YOU WEREN'T EITHER.
BUT THESE LIFE SKILLS OR JUST
CRITICAL --
ARE IN A NON PROFIT THAT I
STARTED A WE WENT TO HIGH SCHOOL
TO DO A SUMMER PROGRAM WE DID
THAT FOR SEVERAL YEARS.
AND ONE YEAR WE SAID WELL WHY
DON'T WE ASK THE STUDENTS WHAT
THEY THINK.
SHOULD BE INCLUDED IN THE SUMMER
PROGRAM.
AT THE TOP OF THE LIST.
AND THIS IS A A POOR WORKING
CLASS IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY --
THEY SAID THE STUDENTS SAID
FINANCIAL LITERACY --
AND I WAS REALLY SURPRISED
TRUTHFULLY BECAUSE I GREW UP OF
THINKING --
WHY DO I NEED FINANCIAL LITERACY
IF I DON'T HAVE ANY MONEY --
WHICH IS OBVIOUSLY A DUMB WAY OF
LOOKING AT IT BUT I'VE LEARNED
OVER THE THAT I HAD THAT.
EARLIER IN MY LIFE I WOULDN'T
HAVE BEEN INTIMIDATED BY IT AND
I WOULD HAVE USED IT IN A USE MY
SKILL IN A SMARTER WAY.
SO -- I
DON'T KNOW ALL THE PARTICULARS
OF THE FUNDING AND I BELIEVE
THAT.
IN A WAY TO BE FOR THEIR
EDUCATED BY MY COLLEAGUES BUT I
DO THINK YOU ARE RAISING VERY
VERY IMPORTANT THEY'RE NOT.
YOU KNOW THE THINGS THAT WE
SHOULD JUST BRUSH TO THE SIDE
YOU'RE RAISING SOME CORE ISSUES --
FOR YOUNG PEOPLE AND SO I
APPRECIATED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SENATOR.
CENTER WILK BY SHARE.
THANK YOU AND SHARE A GREAT
PRESENTATION FACT ALL THE PRISON
AND PRESENTATIONS AS FAR HAVE
BEEN --
EXCELLENT --
I THE I THINK YOU'RE I THINK
YOU'RE RIGHT ON THE MONEY OUT I
WHICH I SCHOOL A LONG TIME AGO
AND I DON'T RECALL IF IT WAS
REQUIRED OR NOT BUT WE HAD WE
HAD A WHOLE SEMESTER.
WHERE WE LEARNED ALL THESE LIFE
SKILLS?
AND IT IS NOT TAUGHT ANYMORE NO
FOR MY OWN CHILDREN I HAD TO TO
TEACH THEM.
ABOUT FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITY
BUT THEY WERE FORTUNATE TO GROW
UP IN A DAY TWO FAST TWO PARENT
HOME.
WITH ENGAGE PARENTS AND I KNOW
THAT'S NOT ALWAYS THE CASE SO MY
DISTRICT IS.
MORE THAN LA COUNTY AND SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY ONE OUT OF
EVERY THREE FOSTER YOUTH IN ALL
OF LA COUNTY.
NOW RESIDES IN IN A VALLEY AND I
THINK ABOUT THOSE STUDENTS AND
AS MENTIONED EARLIER.
THOSE WHOSE TO SUPPLY NEED IT
THE MOST AND THEY'RE AND THEY'RE
NOT GETTING THOSE RESOURCES SO
THAT THE ASSEMBLY CHAIR SHARED --
CHALLENGES.
THAT WE FACE --
WE TYPICALLY HAVE A A TO A TYPE
DEAL LIKE THIS EVERY YEAR THAT
DOESN'T GET ACROSS TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK.
SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU.
TO KEEP BUT KEEP FIGHTING ON
THAT AND ONE DAY MAYBE WE CAN
GET PEOPLE TO TO STEP UP AND DO
THE RIGHT THING OR FIGURE OUT A
A MORE CREATIVE WAY. TO TO MOVE
MANEUVER AGAIN BUT I I JUST
THINK THESE ARE ESENTIAL SKILLS
THAT ALL YOUNG PEOPLE NEED AND
EXCELLENT PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR.
I WOULD JUST SAY THAT I LOVE
LIFE SKILLS I THINK IT'S
WONDERFUL IF YOU CAN GET AGREE
GRADE ON A PAPER BUT ONCE YOU
GET A LITTLE FURTHER ALONG IN
LIFE I KNOW NO ONE HAS NEVER
EVER ASKED ME WHAT WAS YOUR GPA
AND HIGH SCHOOL.
WHAT WAS YOUR GPA IN COLLEGE BUT
WHAT THEY DO WANT TO KNOW IS CAN
YOU ADULT AS YOU WERE SAYING HOW
DO WE DO ADULT AND --
I THINK AS YOU'VE HEARD SOME OF
THIS IS ALREADY IN THE
CURRICULUM HOW DO WE FIND A WAY
TO MAKE SURE IT'S ACTUALLY
HAPPENING I THINK STARTING AS
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH SAID.
STARTING AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
LEVEL AND MEETING WITH YOUR
SUPERINTENDENTS I KNOW THE
SCHOOLS IN MY DISTRICT THE VERY
ON WHETHER OR NOT THEY OFFER
THESE LIFE SKILLS.
I HAD IN SCHOOLS IN ECONOMICS
AND BACK THEN WE DID LEARN HOW
TO BALANCE A CHECKBOOK BUT I'M A
LOT OLDER THAN ALL OF YOU PRY
OLDER THAN YOUR PARENTS.
SO WE HAVE TO KEEP UP ALSO WITH
THE TIMES --
BUT WHAT I WOULD COMMIT TO USE
IF I SPEAKING TO YOUR
SUPERINTENDENTS I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO DO THAT WE JUST RECENTLY DID
A FINANCIAL LITERACY CLASS FOR
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS ARE --
EVENT IN OUR DISTRICT WE AT A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY YOUNG MEN
RANDY FOR THE WOMEN TO BUT WE DO
YOUNG MEN'S CONFERENCE AS WELL
AND THEY PAIRED UP AND THEY WERE
EACH GIVEN A JOB AND TOLD HOW
MUCH THEY MADE.
AND THEN THEY HAD THE BUDGET FOR
THEIR CHILDREN FOR EXPENSES --
AND WE WERE SURPRISED AS I AM
SURPRISE IT TO AS HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS ARE BRINGING THIS TO US
SO YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT IT SO
MEANS IT'S IMPORTANT TEO.
SO WE APPRECIATE THAT AND WE
THINK THE CURRICULUM ALREADY
ALLOWS FOR THIS BUT WE NEED TO
ALL COLLECTIVELY FIGURE OUT HOW
DO WE ACTUALLY MAKE SURE IT'S
HAPPENING.
SO THANK YOU ANY FURTHER CLOSING
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU GENTLEMAN.
ALL RIGHT NEXT WE ARE GOING TO
HEAR FROM.
IOWA SIMONE SOMEONE EVAN WAS
ALWAYS ANNALISA ESCAMBIA.
AND I'M SORRY IF I SAID YOUR
NAME INCORRECTLY [inaudible]
WELCOME.
GREETINGS CHAIRWOMAN LEYVA
CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL AND HONORABLE
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE AND
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES ON EDUCATION.
MY NAME IS EVAN ROSE ALL US I'M
A SENIOR AT SAMMY TO HIGH IN THE
SAN BENITO HIGH SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN.
SAN BENITO COUNTY.
MY NAME IS AYE WHICH MEN I AM A
JUNIOR AT CREATE A HIGH SCHOOL
IN THE QATARI RUNNER PARK SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
IN SET NOT INSANELY NO COUNTY IN
CINEMA COUNTY.
VERY GOOD MY NAME IS LIZ ASKING
ME I'M A SENIOR AT SAN MARINO
HIGH SCHOOL IN SAN MARINO IN THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY.
VICTIM RIGHTS LAWCENTER SENIOR
LEGAL COUNSEL COLBY PRINTER
STATED HOWEVER BAD YOU THINK
THAT A COLLEGE CAMPUSES LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY IS ON SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
GO BACK FIFTEEN YEARS BEFORE AND
THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE LOOKING OUT
FOR HIGH SCHOOLS.
THE LACK OF ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY INVOLVING SEXUAL
ABUSE AND HARASSMENT CASES ON
HIGH SCHOOL CAMPUSES HAS LED TO
THE MISTREATMENT OF SUCH CASES.
AND HAS CULTIVATED A SENSE OF
MISTRUST AND RELATIONSHIPS AMONG
STUDENTS AND FACULTY.
THIS IS DETRIMENTAL TO
FACILITATING EFFECTIVE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT.
WE PROPOSE CALIFORNIA MANDATE
ALL SCHOOLS CLEARLY PUBLICIZE
THEIR SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND
ASSAULT PROTOCOLS IN FREQUENTED
PLACES WITHIN SCHOOLS MAKING IT
ACCESSIBLE TO THEIR STUDENT BODY.
AS WELL AS POST THE NUMBER OF
SUSPENSIONS AND EXPULSIONS
RELATING TO SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
SEXUAL HARASSMENT ON THE SCHOOL
DASHBOARD UNDER THE EXISTING
PUBLISHED EXPULSION AND
SUSPENSION NUMBERS.
IN MANY CASES IT IS THE FEAR OF
JUDGMENT AND SOCIETAL STIGMA AS
HOLDING STUDENTS BACK FROM
COMING FORWARD AND SHARING THEIR
TRAUMA.
AT SAN BENITO HIGH SCHOOL A
STUDENT WAS BULLIED FOR PORTING
A SEXUAL ASSAULT.
FRIENDS OF THE PERPETRATOR WOULD
PUSH IT SCHOOL AND SAY IS THAT
CONSIDERED RAPE.
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T WANT TO
BELIEVE THE PERSON IN QUESTION
ACTUALLY DID THIS.
THIS MADE OTHER SHIED AWAY FROM
BRINGING UP THEIR OWN SITUATIONS
TO SCHOOL AUTHORITIES AFTER
SEEING THE TREATMENT SHE
RECEIVED FOR REPORTING HER SALT.
THE SITUATION IS NOT UNCOMMON
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL SEXUAL
VIOLENCE RESOURCE CENTER ONLY
12% OF ALL ABUSE AGAINST
CHILDREN SEXUAL ABUSE AGAINST
CHILDREN IS EVER REPORTED TO
AUTHORITIES.
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE APPROXIMATELY 70% OF
RAPE AND ASSAULT VICTIMS
EXPERIENCE MODERATE TO SEVERE
DISTRESS.
A LARGER PERCENTAGE THAN FOR ANY
OTHER VIOLENT CRIME.
THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE THERE NEEDS
TO BE A RADICAL CHANGE IN THE
WAY STUDENTS ARE EDUCATED ON
REPORTING INSTANCES OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND HARASSMENT.
OUR GROUP ASKED OURSELVES WHAT
STEPS WE SHOULD TAKE IF WE REFER
TO FACE A SIMILAR SITUATION OF
HAVING TO REPORT SEXUAL
HARASSMENT OR ASSAULT.
YOU MUST NEW WHO WE WOULD TURN
TO OR WHAT STEPS WE WOULD NEED
TO TAKE TO REPORT AN INCIDENT.
WITH KNOWLEDGE THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH REMARK AIMS TO
STANDARDIZE HEALTH EDUCATION
WITH CURRICULA INVOLVING HEALTHY
POSITIVE AND SAFE RELATIONSHIPS
AND BEHAVIORS.
WE HOPE THAT THIS PROPOSAL WILL
EXPAND UPON AND REINFORCE
REVISIONS MADE AND SERVICE BOTH
A PROACTIVE AND REACTIVE
SOLUTION TO THE MISTREATMENT OF
THESE CASES WITH IN CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS.
IN ADDITION TO WHAT MY COLLEAGUE
LIZ HAS PRESENTED MY PEERS AND I
FIND THAT IT IS IN THE PUBLIC
RIGHT TO HAVE EASILY ACCESSIBLE
STATISTICS.
REGARDING THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
EITHER SUSPENDED OR EXPELLED FOR
ANY CRIMES RELATING TO SEXUAL
SOUL OR HARASSMENT.
WHILE KEEPING THE INFORMATION OF
ALL ARTIES INVOLVED CONFLICT
COMPLETELY CONFIDENTIAL.
THE STATISTICS SHALL BE ADDED TO
THE EXISTING DATA ON THIS
pWHICH AIMS TO INFORM THE
COMMUNITY ON WHETHER OR NOT
SCHOOLS ARE MEETING STATE
STANDARDS IN EDUCATION AND
DISCIPLINE.
AB THEIR MINIMUM WE REQUIRE
SCHOOLS TO POST A RATE AT WHICH
STUDENTS ARE SUSPENDED OR
EXPELLED WITH NO REAL EXPANDED
LIST ON THE REASONS THERE OF
THEREFORE.
THE CURRENT DATA THAT IS
PROVIDED IT IS INSUFFICIENT.
THIS LIST UNDER OUR PROPOSAL
SHALL INCLUDE A SECTION ON THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE SUSPENDED OR
EXPELLED FOR ALL SEX RELATED
OFFENSES.
THE PRIVACY OF ALL STUDENTS
WOULD BE ABSOLUTELY PROTECTED AS
IT WOULD ONLY INVOLVE NUMBERS NO
NAMES OR OTHER INFORMATION THAT
MIGHT THAT MAY REVEAL THE
IDENTITY.
OF ANYONE THAT IS A VICTIM OR
ANYONE THAT HAS BEEN SUSPENDED
OR EXPELLED.
IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT THIS
INFORMATION IS PROVIDED TO THE
PUBLIC AS IT ONCE OR
TRANSPARENCY AND THUS ENCOURAGE
SCHOOLS PURSUE ACTION IN
DECREASING SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
HARASSMENT INCIDENTS.
IN FEAR OF HARMING THE SCHOOL'S
REPUTATION AND THUS TURNING AWAY
FUTURE STUDENTS FROM POSSIBLE
ENROLLMENTS.
IT IS ALSO ON THE RIGHTS OF THE
STUDENTS AND BY EXTENSION THE
PARENTS TO HAVE THIS INFORMATION
IN ORDER TO OBTAIN A SAFER
COMMUNITY. FOR COMMUNITY
IGNORANT OF THE EXTENT OF THE DO
NOTHING TO EFFECTIVELY ADDRESS
IT.
BY POSTING NUMBERS THE SCHOOLS
WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR
ADDRESSING THE PROBLEM IN A
MEANINGFUL MATTER.
WHICH ONE SOURCE IN SAFETY AND
RESULTANTLY ALLOW PARENTS TO
FEEL MORE COMFORTABLE SENDING
THEIR CHILDREN TO OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS.
THIS MEASURE OF ACCOUNTABILITY
WILL ALLOW SCHOOLS TO ADDRESS
THE PROBLEM EARLY ON AND
POSSIBLY HOLD A TOXIC MINDSET
THAT CAN ONLY GROWN TO FUTURE
CRIMES WHEN THE STUDENTS ANSWER
THE OUTSIDE WORLD.
IT IS A THAT SPORTS PURPOSE TO
HOLD SCHOOLS ACCOUNTABLE AND
WITH THIS ADDED INFORMATION
ITSELF FOR SCHOOLS TO BECOME
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THE ISSUES
CAUSED BY SEXUAL SOUL FOR IT IS
A STUDENTS FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT. TO
FEEL SAFE ON CAMPUS.
THE INFORMATION WILL PUSH THE
SCHOOLS TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES.
HOLDING THEM LIABLE FOR THE
BEHAVIOR OF THEIR STUDENTS AND
THUS ALLOWING THE COMMUNITY TO
FEEL MORE AT EASE WITH THOSE IN
CHARGE OF MY PEERS FUTURE.
THIS PROPOSAL EFFECTIVELY
ADDRESSES THE LACK OF
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
SURROUNDING SEXUAL HARASSMENT
ACROSS THE STATE.
WHICH WAS IDENTIFIED AS THE CORE
ISSUES SURROUNDING SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND HARASSMENT BY OUR
DELEGATION.
WE BELIEVE THAT POSTING CLEAR
STEPS FOR VICTIMS FOR VICTIMS OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND ASSAULT.
WILL ENSURE THAT STUDENTS WHO
ARE CONSIDERING COMING FORWARD
ARE INFORMED OF THEIR RIGHTS AND
KNOW THAT THEIR SUPPORTED BOTH
MORALLY AND LEGALLY BY THEIR
COMMUNITY.
THE PRESENCE OF THESE POSTERS
AND COMMONLY FREQUENTED AREAS OF
THE SCHOOL WOULD NORMALIZE
HEALTHY CONVERSATIONS AROUND
SEXUAL HARASSMENT AND ASSAULT.
CURRENTLY STUDENTS ARE WIDELY ON
AWARE OF THEIR RIGHTS AND THE
PROTOCOL SURROUNDING ACCUSATIONS
OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT.
AND WOULD ONLY FIND THEIR FULL
EXTENT AFTER LENGTHY RESEARCH
INTO THE SUBJECT.
THE EASE OF ACCESS OF THIS
INFORMATION COULD BE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A CRIME GOING
UNREPORTED AND A PERPETRATOR
BEING BROUGHT TO JUSTICE.
THE CONTENT OF THESE POSTERS
WILL PREPARE STUDENTS FOR FUTURE
ENCOUNTERS SOMETHING THAT IS
IMPLICIT IN THE DEFINITION OF
EDUCATION.
THE REVISION TO THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH FRAMEWORK WORKS AND
SYMBIOTICALLY WITH OUR PROPOSAL.
THE CONVERSATIONS IN THE
CLASSROOM AND CITED BY THE
UPDATED HEALTH REMARK WILL BE
EXTENDED OUTSIDE OF THE
CLASSROOM AND INTO THE STUDENTS
GREATER LIVES BY THE PUBLISHED
PROTOCOLS TO BE POSTED IN THE
COMMON AREAS OF SCHOOLS.
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THESE
POSTED PROTOCOLS IN EVERY SCHOOL
AND THE ADDITION TO THE SECTION
OF THE DASHBOARD PROMOTE
TRANSPARENCY SURROUNDING SEXUAL
MISCONDUCT IN SCHOOLS ACROSS THE
STATE.
AND TERMINATE THE TOXIC CLIMATE
THAT IS PERPETUATED WITHOUT THEM.
THIS PROPOSAL PROVIDES A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA TO PROTECT THE FUTURE
GENERATIONS FROM THE PAINS OF
THE PAST.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY WELL PRESENTED.
MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU AGAIN VERY WELL
PRESENTED VERY GOOD JOB --
JUST A COUPLE GOOD MAYBE A
COMMENT AND A QUESTION WITH
REGARD TO THE INFORMATION
CAMPAIGN I ABSOLUTELY AGREE WITH
YOU -- THAT
SHOULD BE.
DONE NOW.
IT SHOULDN'T REQUIRE A LOT I
THINK ANY PROACTIVE SCHOOL
LEADER WOULD BE DOING THAT RIGHT
NOW AND IT WOULD BE DONE ON AN
ONGOING BASIS SO THAT ALL THE
STUDENTS.
WOULD KNOW THE POLICY BE ABLE
SEE THE POLICY AND APPRECIATE
AND RESPECT.
THE POLICY SO I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT.
WITH REGARD TO THE DATA WHERE
YOU WANT TO PARSE IT APART TAKEN
TAKEN APART AND INTO DIFFERENT
DIRECTIONS --
WHAT WHAT WOULD THAT MEMBERS OR
EVEN SCHOOL HAS LOW NUMBERS WHAT
DO YOU THINK THAT WOULD PROVE
WHAT WOULD WHAT WOULD ONE DO
WITH THAT DATA DID YOU DO YOU
KNOW AT THIS POINT --
I THINK THE WAY THAT OUR GROUP
AND OUR DELEGATION WERE
ENVISIONING IT IS IT WAS MORE
JUST INFORMATION RATHER THAN
LIKE PROVING A POINT ASKED
WHETHER.
THE SCHOOL HAD A HIGHER
PERCENTAGE THAN OTHERS OTHER
SCHOOLS BECAUSE IT'S IMPORTANT
TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THAT
SCHOOLS ARE OFTEN IN VARIOUS
DIFFERENT COMMUNITIES WITH
VARIOUS DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS SO.
IT'S NOT SO MUCH PROVING THAT%
ONE SCHOOL HAS MORE THAN THE
OTHER ONE SCHOOL IS BETTER THAN
THE OTHER IT'S MOSTLY JUST TO
KEEP THE STUDENTS AND THE
PARENTS INFORMED ABOUT --
EXACTLY WHAT THEY'RE STEPPING
INTO WHAT'S GOING ON AROUND THEM
REGARDLESS OF NOT WHETHER IT'S
HAPPENING EXACTLY TO THEM.
EXCELLENT SIR THANK YOU.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
I DO I JUST HAD A QUESTION ON IT.
AND I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING THAT
THE CHAIR SAID SO --
I KNOW COLLEGES HAVE TO REPORT
TO THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SO IT
IS YOUR DATA KIND OF BE LIKE THE
SAME CATEGORY SAYS IS IS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IF YOU TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT ARE.
PLEASE CRISIS LIKE THE LAST
COUPLE DAYS RIGHT SO YEAH.
IN OUR PROPOSAL WE WERE
EXPECTING THAT WE WANTED TO PUT
IT UNDER THE EXPULSION AND
SUSPENSION NUMBERS JUST TO
FURTHER CLARIFY SO RIGHT NOW
IT'S NOT REALLY.
NOTHING'S REALLY LISTED IT'S
JUST SUSPENSION AND EXPULSION
THERE'S NOT --
JUST SO THAT SAID SO DOES EVEN
IF.
BECAUSE A LOT OF EXPULSIONS HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH YOU KNOW
BEING A SEXUAL PREDATOR SO.
WE JUST WANT TO HAVE IT LISTED
OUT SPECIFICALLY SO THERE WAS NO
MISCOMMUNICATION OR ANY WAY.
TO KIND OF LOOK AT IT AND NOT
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING OKAY
GREAT THANK YOU.
YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR SO I WANNA
MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE ASKING FOR HELP SORRY NO
NO GO RIGHT AHEAD.
OKAY VERY GOOD --
SIR THANK YOU CATCHER SO MY
QUESTION IS RIGHT NOW YOU SAY
THAT YOU THERE'S NO WAY TO KNOW
WITH THE SEXUAL ASSAULT OR
HARASSMENT POLICIES ARE ON
CAMPUS BECAUSE IT'S NOT POSTED
IS THAT CORRECT.
I'VE NEVER SEEN ANYTHING POSTED
OKAY IF YOU WANTED TO KNOW WHAT
THE POLICY WAS IS THERE ANY
AVENUE TO FIND OUT WHAT THE
POLICY IS.
I DO I AM SURE IN THERE THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE POSTED IN SLIGHT
SCHOOLS MUSCLES HAVE BEEN POSTED
SOMEWHERE IT'S JUST VERY
DIFFICULT TO ACCESS AND A BIG
PART OF OUR PROPOSALS TO MAKE IT
ACCESSIBLE.
BUT I AGREE WITH YOU A 100% --
AND SOMETIMES WE CAN STOP MAKING
SURE PEOPLE ARE EDUCATED ON THAT
BAD BEHAVIOR SO VERY INTERESTED
IN YOUR PROPOSAL AND AFTER THIS
AND WHEN YOU HAVE TIME.
I'D LIKE YOU TO SPEAK WITH MY
STAFF AND SEE IF THERE'S
SOMETHING WE CAN MOVE FORWARD.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SMITH AND THEN
SENATOR TORONTO.
I THANK YOU SO I THINK WHAT
YOU'VE ACHIEVED BY TYING THIS TO
DASHBOARD REPORTING IS KIND OF
THE SWEET SPOT OF LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS SOMETIMES AND THAT IS
HOW DO YOU ENSURE A MEASURE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY.
AND THERE IS NO GREATER
INCENTIVE FOR DISTRICT TO TACKLE
A PROBLEM THAN TO BE ACCOUNTABLE
TO REPORT ON THAT PROBLEM AND I
SO I THINK I'M I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO WORK IN CONJUNCTION WITH
SENATOR LABOR'S OFFICE.
ON ENSURING THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
MOVE FORWARD ON THIS.
VERY GOOD SENATOR ALSO YEAH I'M
A LITTLE I'M IGNORANT OF THIS IS
A SEXUAL ASSAULT PROTOCOL
REQUIRED NOW.
IN ALL SCHOOLS.
SO YOU'RE TAKING THE NEXT STEP
WHICH IS WHAT IT'S SUPPOSED TO
EXIST.
THAT TO MAKE IT ACCESSIBLE TO
THE STUDENTS.
AND HAVE YOU I THINK IT'S A
FOLLOW UP TO SENATOR LAVERS
QUESTION IS.
HAVE YOU ENCOUNTERED A
DIFFICULTY IN GETTING ACCESS TO
IT -- IN.
THE SCHOOLS WERE YOU'VE
DISCUSSED THIS.
PERSONALLY IF I WERE TO HAVE TO
REPORT IN ASSAULT I WOULDN'T
KNOW HOW TO DO THAT I DON'T KNOW
THE PROPER PROTOCOL I WOULD
PROBABLY BE EMBARRASSED TO GO
TALK TO SOMEONE --
AND I WOULD BE KIND OF SCARED IN
A WAY REGARDLESS OF BEING
ASSAULTED I WOULD BE SCARED.
TO TELL A TRUSTED ADULT BECAUSE
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE PROPER
PROTOCOL IS.
AND DO YOU HAVE ACCESS TO OTHER
PROTOCOLS LIKE HANDBOOKS OR OR
THERE ARE OTHER WAYS IN WHICH
OTHER.
POLICIES OR PROCEDURES ARE
COMMUNICATED TO STUDENTS.
FROM IF I MAKE COMMENTS ON I
REMEMBER --
IN THE BEGINNING OF THIS SCHOOL
YEAR THAT WE HAVE A DAILY
BULLETIN ARE HIGH SCHOOL WHERE --
IT READS THE NEWS AND I DO
REMEMBER IN THE BEGINNING THEY
MENTIONED SOMETHING ABOUT IT
HOWEVER.
IT HASN'T REALLY BEEN MENTIONED
AGAIN AND I HAVE NO IDEA WHERE
TO GO FOR ANYTHING IT WAS
MENTIONED ONCE AND IT'S KIND OF
NEVER MENTIONED AGAIN.
SHE WAS ON OTHER SUBJECTS.
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES ON OTHER
SUBJECTS ARE THOSE COMMUNICATED
OR DONE IN A BROADER WAY ARE
GIVEN OUT TO OTHER PEOPLE NOT
SPECIFICALLY THE SEXUAL ASSAULT.
ARMED FOR BULLYING THERE'S A LOT
OF BULLYING POSTERS I CAN GO
INTO ANY CLASSROOM AND THERE'S
THIS WE TA POSTER AND IT HAS
LIKE A CELL PHONE AND THERE'S
LIKE A CYBER BULLYING.
AND HAS THE PHONE NUMBER AND YOU
THE RIGHT DIRECTION SO I THINK
WE WOULD LIKE TO HAVE SOMETHING
VERY SIMILAR WHERE IT'S NOT
ECESSARILY LIKE.
PROTOCOL IN LEGISLATIVE LANGUAGE
THAT HIGH SCHOOLERS CAN'T
UNDERSTAND IT'S SOMETHING THAT
SUCCESSFUL SOMETHING THAT'S
UNDERSTANDABLE THAT WOULD TAKE A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
TOWARDS MAKING EVERYTHING
TRANSPARENT AND MAKING IT.
AN ISSUE THAT ISN'T SO MUCH I'M
EMBARRASSED I DON'T KNOW WHO TO
TALK TO IT'S I'M.
SCARED BUT I KNOW EXACTLY WHO I
NEED TO TALK TO YOU HOW TO
COMMUNICATE IT.
THANK YOU VERY GOOD LET'S TALK
FURTHER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
ALRIGHT OUR NEXT IN THE LAST
PANEL IS ON STATE FUNDING LIKE
DIVIDE UP ARVIN HURRY.
RITUAL LOU AND KENNETH CAM
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY
[inaudible] EIGHT GOOD MORNING.
CHAIRWOMAN LEYVA.
CHAIRMAN O'DONNELL HIS TEAM
MEMBERS AND STAFF FIRST AND
FOREMOST THANK YOU.
I THANK YOU FOR GIVING THE
STUDENTS OF CALIFORNIA TO EXPAND
THE OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS THEIR
VOICES AND BE THE CHANGE THAT
THEY SEEK IN THEIR EDUCATION
SYSTEM.
MY NAME IS ART AND HER HEARING
AND I'M THE GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF STUDENT COUNCILS.
WHEN I'M NOT DOING THIS I'M A
SENIOR AT BERKELEY HIGH SCHOOL?
MY NAME IS KIND OF KIM AND I AM
THE EDUCATIONAL POLICY DIRECTOR
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS IN ADDITION TO
BEING A SENIOR APRYL AND HIGH
SCHOOL.
MY NAME IS RACHEL LOU AND I
SERVICES STATE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS.
I AM CURRENTLY A SENIOR AT SOUTH
PASADENA HIGH SCHOOL IN
SOUTHWEST UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
THIS ORGANIZATION TASK IS NEAR
AND DEAR TO MY HEART.
AND TO THE HEARTS OF MANY OTHER
STUDENTS NOT JUST ACROSS THE
STATE BUT ACROSS THE SPAN OF
DECADES.
A LITTLE BIT OF HISTORY.
CASK WAS FOUNDED SEVENTY TWO
YEARS AGO BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS TO PROVIDE
STUDENTS WITH THE SKILLS
NECESSARY TO BECOME FUTURE
LEADERS AND PILLARS OF THEIR
RESPECTIVE COMMUNITIES.
SKILLS THEY COULD USE FOR THE
REST OF THEIR LIVES.
OVER THE YEARS ORGANIZATION IS
EXPANDED OUR ROLE BY ENHANCING
THE ROLE OF STUDENT VOICE AND
THE CALIFORNIA EDUCATION
DECISION MAKING PROCESS WITHOUT
A LOCAL LEVEL IN OUR DISTRICTS.
AND HERE AND SACRAMENTO.
LAST LEGISLATIVE CYCLE CAST
PASSED TWO BILLS AB TWO SIX ONE
AND SP.
FOUR SIX EIGHT AB TWO SIX ONE
WAS AUTHORED BY THAT ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND NOW STATE
SUPERINTENDENT OF PUBLIC
INSTRUCTION TONY THURMOND AND IT
GAVE STUDENT BOARD MEMBERS.
DISTRICT BOARD MEMBERS
PREFERENTIAL VOTING RIGHTS AS
BEFORE SIX EIGHT WAS AUTHORED BY
THE HONORABLE CHAIRWOMAN SENATOR
LEYVA AND ALLOWED FOR STUDENT
BOARD MEMBERS TO HAVE ACCESS TO
OPEN SESSION MATERIALS.
THIS WASN'T A ONE OFF THING
EITHER. ONE OF OUR FIRST
ACHIEVEMENTS WAS PLACING A
STUDENT BOARD MEMBER ON THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION AND WE
HAVE PASSED A WIDE ARRAY OF
STUDENT BILL SINCE.
SO THIS LEGISLATIVE CYCLE I'VE
ALREADY GOTTEN A FEW BILLS SENT
TO LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL RANGING
FROM CREATING A WHOLE NEW
ENVIRONMENTAL AWARD SYSTEM FOR
DISTRICTS TO GIVING STUDENT
BOARD MEMBERS MOTIONING HOURS.
ATTACHED TO EACH PROPOSAL THAT
YOUR OFFICE IS NOW HAVE ISM BILL
LANGUAGE THAT THE STUDENTS
BEHIND ME AND I'VE CREATED FOR
THEIR IDEAS AND I IMPLORE EACH
AND EVERYONE OF YOU TO SEND.
THESE TO LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL AS
WELL ALREADY THANKS TO SENATOR
SKINNER'S OFFICE THE BATHROOM
BILL HAS BEEN SENT AND IT'S FUN
BACKED BUT ONLY FOR NOW.
GAS VOICE HAS ALWAYS BEEN STRONG.
ALWAYS.
BUT IT'S ULTIMATELY THE
LEGISLATURE THAT HAS THE POWER
TO TAKE THAT VOICE AND
TRANSLATED INTO CHANGE.
BETWEEN NINETEEN EIGHTY FIVE AND
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE COSCO'S
RECEIVED ANNUAL STATE FUNDING AS
PART OF THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
HOWEVER WHEN CATEGORICAL FUNDING
WAS ELIMINATED FROM THE BUDGET
OUR LINE ITEM WAS TAKEN AWAY
WITH IT.
EVER SINCE THEN OUR FUNDING HAS
COME FROM FEES REQUIRED FROM
SERVICES DONATIONS AND GRANTS.
ARE MAJOR IN YOUR COFFEE
CONFERENCES AND PROGRAMS UCH AS
THE YOUTH ACTION SUMMIT OF
CALIFORNIA AND THIS PROGRAM AS
WELL CAN COST AN AVERAGE OF SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER STUDENT.
THESE CONFERENCES ARE EXPENSIVE
TO ATTEND BUT ONE CASK WAS STILL
RECEIVING FUNDING BY THE STATE.
THEY COST LESS THAN A LOT FOR
MORE DIVERSE DELEGATION TO THE
AVAILABILITY OF SCHOLARSHIPS TO
GET STUDENTS TO ATTEND PROGRAMS.
CAST REMAINS ONE OF THE GREATEST
CHOICES OF MY LIFE AND I WILL
NEVER REGRET IT.
BUT IT WOULD IS REGRETTABLE
HOWEVER IS A FACT THAT STUDENTS
THAT STAND TO BENEFIT THE MOST
FROM OUR LEADERSHIP TRAINING-CANNOT AFFORD THEM IN OUR POOLER
REPRESENTATION DESPITE ALL
EFFORTS TO THE CONTRARY.
CONTINUE TO DIMINISH.
THE STUDENTS AND THERE IS A
CALIFORNIA LEAST REPRESENTED
WITHIN CAST CONTINUE TO NOT ONLY
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN
LEADING INTO AN UNENDING CYCLE
THE ONLY YOUR SUPPORT CAN HELP
BREAK.
WE HAVE MADE CONSISTENT EFFORTS
TO INCLUDE ALL VOICES.
BUT IS BECOME NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE
TO DO SO A CERTAIN GROUPS OF
STUDENTS SIMPLY CAN'T AFFORD TO
ATTEND.
CAST CANNOT AFFORD TO SEND LOW
INCOME STUDENTS PROGRAMS EVEN IF
THEY APPLY FOR AND QUALIFY FOR
SCHOLARSHIPS BECAUSE WITHOUT THE
CURRENT LACKEY A STUDY STATE
FUNDING.
THERE'S FAR TOO LITTLE MONEY FOR
SCHOLARSHIPS.
AS A RESULT.
WE'RE ASKING THE LEGISLATURE TO
PROPOSE AN AUGMENTATION TO THE
STATE BUDGET FOR ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
STUDENT COUNCILS.
AND THIS IS AN UNPRECEDENTED
EITHER --
YOUTH ORGANIZATIONS LIKE --
THE YMCA'S YOUTH IN GOVERNMENT
ACTUALLY RECEIVED A ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLAR LINE ITEM
IN THE TWENTY THIRTEEN TWENTY
FOURTEEN STATE BUDGET.
NEARLY ALL OF THESE FUNDS.
WILL BE GOING TO US ARE WOULD BE
GOING TO US WILL BE USED IN
ORDER TO CONTINUE PROVIDING THE
STUDENT PLATFORMS THAT MOTIVATED
US IN THE FIRST PLACE TO COME
HERE. TO CONDUCT LEADERSHIP
TRAINING IN THAT WE SEEK TO BE
WE NEED THE SUPPORT FROM THE
STATE TO CONTINUE TO SURVIVE. TOBE SPECIFIC EVEN MORE SPECIFIC
TWO THIRDS OF THIS MONEY WILL GO
TOWARD STUDENTS SCHOLARSHIPS FOR
OUR CONFERENCES.
THAT'S ABOUT A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS THIS WOULD EFFECTIVELY
ELIMINATE THE BARRIEROF ENTRY
ENSURING THAT NO STUDENT WHO IS
INTERESTED IS TURNED AWAY FROM
ANY OF OUR EXTRAORDINARY
EXPERIENCES AS A RESULT OF FIRE
FAMILY FINANCES.
BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE THAT THAT
IS SIMPLY NOT FAIR.
IT'S COMPLETELY AND I UNDERSTAND
IT'S COMPLETELY POSSIBLE TO
BELIEVE THAT WE DON'T NEED THE
STATE FUNDING BECAUSE WE'RE HERE
AREN'T WE BUT BUT WE'RE NOT.
WE'RE NOT ALL HERE IN OTHER
WORDS THERE ARE CURRENTLY THE WE
ARE CURRENTLY PRESENTING TO THIS
INCREDIBLE DELEGATION OF THIRTY
TWO STUDENTS THE STUDENTS ARE
ULTIMATELY NOT REPRESENTATIVE.
OF ALL OF CALIFORNIA MOST OF IT.
PROBABLY YES.
BUT WE CAN DO MORE IN TO US THIS
IS A PRESSING ISSUE. FOR STUDENT
VOICE TO TRULY BE REFLECTIVE OF
THE ENTIRE STATE WE NEED TO
EXTEND AN OPEN INVITATION TO
EVERY SINGLE STUDENT OUT THERE
AND THIS IS WHAT NEED BASED
SCHOLARSHIPS DO.
THIS AMOUNT OF MONEY IS REALLY
AN INVESTMENT IN THE FUTURE OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS IT GIVES US
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO
EMPOWER STUDENTS FROM ACROSS THE
STATE.
THROUGHOUT BECAUSE HE BASED
RESEARCH AND ACTION ADDITIONALLY
IT ALLOWS US TO CONTINUE TO
REPRESENT THE DIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA'S SIX POINT THREE
MILLION STUDENTS.
NOT JUST THE SELECT FEW.
WE PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS SEES AS YOU
ALL HAVE MENTIONED.
AS WE CONTINUOUSLY PROVIDE
LEGISLATORS AND OTHER EDUCATION
POLICY MAKERS WITH INSIGHTS ON
STUDENT OPINION.
THAT CAN ONLY BE FOUND THROUGH
REAL IN HER TESTIMONIALS.
THROUGH OUR CONFERENCES HERE IN
SACRAMENTO OUR WORK WITH TOP
POLICY MAKERS AND THEIR STAFF
AND OTHER GROUPS INFLUENCING
EDUCATION POLICY WE ARE
CALIFORNIA STUDENT VOICE.
NOT ONLY IS OUR INPUT BEING
VOCALIZED.
BUT STUDENTS SUCH AS THE ONES
BEFORE YOU TODAY ARE
EXPERIENCING CIVIC ENGAGEMENT IN
ITS MOST FORM.
TRANSLATING THEIR IDEALS AND
ISSUES INTO REAL CHANGE THROUGH
THE PROPOSAL'S YOU'VE SEEN TODAY.
INSTEAD OF HIRED CONSULTANTS
PROVIDING YOU WITH INFORMATION
WE PROVIDE REAL FIRST HAND
ACCOUNTS OF HOW POLICY IS BEING
IMPLEMENTED FROM STUDENTS WHO
EXPERIENCE IT IN THEIR EVERYDAY
LIVES.
WITHOUT YOUR SUPPORT THIS
VALUABLE INSIGHT MAY BE LOST.
I HOPE THAT YOU FOUND THESE
PROPOSALS TODAY AND GAUGING AND
INSIGHTFUL.
MOVING FORWARD THEIR STEPS TO BE
TAKEN IN ALL OF OUR TOPICS BUT
WITHOUT FUNDING CONFERENCES LIKE
THIS.
THESE OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS
AND THE LEGISLATURE MAY CEASE TO
EXIST. TWO YEARS AGO MY FIRST
TIME SPEAKING TO THE LEGISLATURE
IN CAMPUS CURRENT SEAT --
WAS A REVELATION IT WAS
INCREDIBLE AND IT IS INCREDIBLE
TO BE RECOGNIZED AND RESPECTED
NOT IN SPITE OF OUR YOUNG AGE
BUT BECAUSE OF OUR UNPARALLELED
STUDENT PERSPECTIVE.
I WAS THE TEXTBOOK DEFINITION OR
BROTHER I STILL AM THE TEXTBOOK
DEFINITION OF AN INVOLVED
STUDENT --
TRYING OUT EVERY YOUTH
ORGANIZATION AVAILABLE TO ME AND
I CAN DEFINITELY TELL YOU AFTER
TRYING.
SO MANY THAT NOTHING COMES CLOSE.
THERE'S NO OTHER ORGANIZATION
THAT IS SO INSISTENT AND
CONSISTENT AS YOU HAVE SEEN FROM
OUR MULTIPLE PRESENTATIONS ON
SEEKING STERN VOICE AND
CULTIVATING SOON POTENTIAL.
IN THE STUDENTS THAT YOU SEE
TODAY SUPPORT WOULD ALLOW FOR
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN MORE
OF THE STUDENTS THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY SEVEN MORE STUDENTS TO
MAKE UP DELEGATION LIKE
DELEGATIONS LIKE BEES.
AND NOT ONLY TO PROVIDE YOU WITH
MORE INSIGHT MORE REPRESENTATIVE
INSIGHT BUT TO BRING THAT
INSIGHT AND TO BRING THAT
EXPERIENCE BOX THEIR LOCAL.
AS A SCHOOL DISTRICTS THIS IS
WHAT WE CALL THE CASF RIPPLE
EFFECT AND WE'D REALLY LIKE TO
SEE IT HAPPEN EVEN MORE SO
THROUGH THE STATE FUNDING.
AS THE LARGEST STAKEHOLDERS IN
THE CALIFORNIA EDUCATION SYSTEM.
STUDENTS NEED TO HAVE THEIR
VOICES HEARD BOTH LOCALLY AT
SCHOOL SITES AND AT THE STATE
LEVEL.
AND CAST PROVIDES STUDENTS WITH
THAT OPPORTUNITY.
CAST BECAUSE INTRODUCED ME TO
THE PEOPLE AND PATHWAYS I COULD
NOT HAVE IMAGINED TWO YEARS AGO.
AND I CANNOT IMAGINE A FUTURE
WITHOUT THIS ORGANIZATION.
ULTIMATELY THE ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS IT IS ACTIVE
SUPPORT TOWARDS THIS DELEGATION.
AND FUTURE ONES AND SIX POINT
THREE MILLION STUDENTS WE ALL
REPRESENT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
AND I NOW OPEN THE FLOOR FOR
COMMENTS AND QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR COMMENTER
QUESTIONS.
ANYONE ELSE YES CENTER CHIANG.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN --
I JUST REALLY WANT TO COMMEND
ALL OF YOU FOR BEING HERE AND
I'M VERY PROUD TO SEE.
STUDENTS FROM MY DISTRICT --
REPRESENTED HERE FROM BERLIN TO
AND I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT YOU
GUYS ARE.
JUST.
SHINING EXAMPLES OF HOW BRIGHTER
FUTURE IS AND I'VE BEEN SO
IMPRESSED WITH THE PRO WITH THE
PRESENTATIONS AND I'D LOVE TO
SEE.
HOW WE CAN HELP FUND THIS
PROGRAM AND TO MAKE SURE THAT WE?
HAVE A MORE DIVERSE --
POPULATION OF STUDENTS COMING UP
TO TO PARTICIPATE SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
THANK YOU SENATOR ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY TO THAT
I THINK WE SHOULD WILL FIND A
WAY TO FIND THAT HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND WE NEED TO PUT
OUR MONEY WHERE OUR MOUTH IS YOU
ARE OUR YOUTH YOU ARE OUR FUTURE.
IT IS ON YOU --
TO FIX WHAT WE HAVE ADULT AS
ADULTS HAVE SCREWED UP IN THE
WORLD SO THE LEAST WE CAN DO IS
FIND YOU A LITTLE BIT OF MONEY.
SO I THINK THERE MAY BE A
COMMITMENT UP HERE FOR ONE OF US
TO FIGURE THAT OUT --
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO GO.
TO YOU CAN.
SIR RUSSELL I'M SORRY.
YES --
EARLIER WE JUST HAVE A QUESTION
I DIDN'T QUITE UNDERSTAND I WAS
ASKING ABOUT.
YOU HAVE THIS --
CHART HERE OF PASSED.
AND IT SHOWS.
ZERO CAN THE BOTTOM I DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
NO MORE FUNDING THERE HAD BEEN
FUNDING AND GET AND IT WAS.
RIGHT IT WAS STOPPED IN TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN YES YES SO
WHAT WAS THE RATIONALE FOR THAT.
MANAGER BUDGET REDUCTIONS I
BELIEVE IT PLEASE MISTER CHAIR I
JUST DIED AT THE I THINK WHAT'S
HAPPENED OVER TIME.
IS THIS EFFORT HAS BEEN FUNDED
ON AN INTERMITTENT BASIS --
SOME YEARS OR FLUSH AND WE WE'VE
ALLOCATED DOLLARS AND I THINK
SPECIFICALLY DURING THE LAST
RECESSION.
THEY ALL MONEY WAS REMOVED FOR
THIS EFFORT AND THEN RECENTLY
WE'VE STARTED TO CLIMB BACK.
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING FOR
THOSE.
THERE WAS NO SPECIFIC REASON FOR
THIS ORGANIZATION OTHER THAN
JUST GENERALLY THE FUNDING OKAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I THINK
KENNETH WE'RE GONNA TURN IT TO
YOU FOR CLOSING YOU MAY STAY
THERE YOU MAY GO TO THE PODIUM
WHICHEVER YOU PREFER.
STAY HERE OKAY --
I WOULD LIKE TO ONCE AGAIN THANK
THE ESTEEM CHAIR LEVIN O'DONNELL
AND THE MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
AND ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES ON
EDUCATION FOR LISTENING TO OUR
PROPOSALS FROM THIS YEAR'S
SEVERAL CONFERENCE.
AND I SINCERELY HOPE THAT VERY
SHORTLY WE CAN TURN THESE IDEAS
KICK STARTED IN THIS ROOM AND
ACTIONS IMPLEMENTED BY YOU THE
SENATE AND ASSEMBLY COMMITTEES
ON EDUCATION.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH COLLEAGUES
ANYBODY HAVE ANY FINAL COMMENTS
A JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PRESENTATIONS TODAY A LOT
OF WORK WENT INTO THEM AND IT
SHOWS -
ACTUALLY MY SISTER-IN-LAW'S
ACTUALLY ONE OF THE DIRECTORS ON
THE BOARD FOR THIS ORGANIZATION
COULD BE HERE TODAY.
SO -- I MEAN
I APPRECIATE THE WORK SHE DOES
TO TO SUPPORT YOUR ORGANIZATION
AND YOU GUYS ARE GREAT.
THE GREAT JOB TODAY.
AND I WOULD JUST ECHO THOSE
COMMENTS AND SAY REALLY TRULY
YOU ARE OUR FUTURE AND WHEN I
LOOK AT EACH OF YOU AND ALL OF
YOU THAT WE'VE HEARD FROM.
OUR FUTURE LOOKS VERY BRIGHT SO
CALIFORNIA IS IN OOD HANDS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR
BEING HERE MAKING A TIME THIS
MORNING.
AND THERE'S SOME THINGS I THINK
WE NEED TO TALK FURTHER ABOUT SO
FIND THE APPROPRIATE PEOPLE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WHERE JOURNAL